तो चलिए सो फाइनली हम लाइव आ चुके
हैं आई थिंक आई एम लाइव नाउ लेट मी चेक
वंस एक बार देख लेते हैं सभी चीजें काम कर
रही है
अपने तरीके से तो आज तो काफी लोग आ चुके
हैं लाइक अभी से 30 पीपल हैव जॉइन एंड 34
लाइक्स पहले से आ चुके हैं
तो एक बार मैं सब चीजें चेक करूंगा बट
यहां पे हैप्पी टीचर्स डे टीचर्स डे ओके
हैप्पी टीचर्स डे एवरी बडी थैंक यू सो मच
थैंक यू थैंक यू थैंक यू काफी लोगों ने
बोला है तो मैं क्या ही बोलू थैंक यू सो
मच आप सबका इतना सपोर्ट है प्यार है सब
कुछ है एंड ट्स वाई मुझे एक इनकरेजमेंट है
ठीक है ट्स
वई वी आर हियर ऑन दिस चैनल ठीक है तो चलिए
तो आज सभी को जवाइन करने देते हैं थोड़ी
देर एंड आज कुछ स्टार्ट करते हैं एंड आज
आप सबके लिए एक बहुत बड़ा सरप्राइज है एक
एक गिफ्ट है मेरे साइड से छोटा सा गिफ्ट
रहेगा आप सबके लिए छोटा सा गिफ्ट रहेगा आप
सबके लिए तो देखते हैं वो गिफ्ट किस किसको
मिल पाता है मैंने पहले ही अनाउंस कर दिया
था उस गिफ्ट के बारे में ऑलरेडी तो आप
सबको आई थिंक पता चल गया होगा राइट बट
काफी कम लोग है अभी तो सभी को आ जाने देते
हैं पहले लेट एवरी बडी जॉइन थैंक यू थैंक
यू थैंक यू सुमित थैंक यू कृष्णा थैंक यू
शमीम थैंक यू थारा भाई थैंक यू किरण थैंक
यू दर्श दर्श थैंक यू ज्ञानेश
अनंद सबको धन्यवाद भाई हैप्पी टीचर्स डे
टू एवरीबॉडी
चलिए तो आज का टॉपिक तो हम स्टार्ट करेंगे
आज की टॉपिक बहुत शानदार होने वाली है टू
फैक्टर ऑथेंटिकेशन और मल्टी फैक्टर
ऑथेंटिकेशन की मिस कन्फेशन की वजह से किस
तरीके से आप वलने बिलिटी फाइंड कर सकते
हैं एंड काफी अच्छे तरीके से अगर आप
रिपोर्ट क्रिएट करते हैं इस टॉपिक के ऊपर
ना इस बग के ऊपर तो आपको बाउंट भी मिल
सकती है रिवॉर्ड हॉल ऑफ फेम वगैरह मिल
सकता है लेकिन रिपोर्ट अच्छा होना चाहिए
तो इसको हम स्टार्ट करेंगे बट
स्टिल आएगी आएगी सभी आएगी 74 पीपल आर हियर
तो स्टार्ट करते हैं एंड आप सबको मैं पहले
ही क्लियर बता देता हूं आज टीचर्स डे है
फथ ऑफ सितंबर अ यह काफी काफी एक अपने आप
में बेहतरीन एक दिन या एक एक शुभ घड़ी मान
सकते हैं आप शुभ दिन मान सकते हैं क्योंकि
आज के दिन हम उन सभी टीचर्स को याद करते
हैं जो एक्चुअली किसी स्टूडेंट के लाइफ
में वैल्यू ऐड करते हैं मैं उन टीचर्स की
बात नहीं कर रहा आज के टाइम आज की जो
टीचर्स है उनके बारे में बात नहीं कर रहा
आज के बहुत सारे ऐसे टीचर्स हैं जो
काफी लाइक चीजें डिफरेंट तरीके से करते
हैं आई विल नॉट कोट दोस थिंग्स अभी तो
पॉजिटिव रहते हैं फिलहाल तो उन टीचर्स के
लिए यह टीचर्स डे स्पेशल हो जाता है जो
टीचर्स बच्चों के लाइफ में वैल्यू ऐड करते
हैं किसी भी तरीके से ऐड कर रहे हो कैसे
भी ऐड कर रहे हो एक सिंगल वैल्यू एक सिंगल
छोटी सी वैल्यू एक छोटा सा जो अगर वैल्यू
ऐड हो जाता है तो वह उन टीचर्स को आज मेरे
तरफ से नमन एंड हैप्पी टीचर्स डे टू ऑल ऑफ
देम जिनसे मैंने सीखा है जिनसे मैंने कुछ
भी सीखा है एक लेटर एक वर्ड एक वर्ड भी
सीखा है उनको हैप्पी टीचर्स डे चलिए तो आज
टीचर्स डे पे आप सबको मैंने पहले ही बोल
रखा था आप सबको पता है ना कि मेरे तरफ से
आप सबको एक ट्रीट मिलने वाली है अब मैं
बहुत ज्यादा कोई ऐसा करोड़पति या ऐसे तो
नहीं बैठा हूं कि मैं आपको बहुत बड़ा
गिफ्ट कोई दे दूंगा छोटा सा गिफ्ट आपको
मैं दे सकता हूं छोटी सी जो गिफ्ट है वह
मैं आपको दे सकता
हूं एंड उसमें मैंने आप सबको बताया था
हमारे
में वीडियो में चले जाइए किसी भी लाइव
सेक्शन में रिसेंट यहां पे डिस्क्रिप्शन
को ओपन कीजिए यहां पे आपको ना
whatsapp.in पेज है हमारी कंपनी की अ
डेनिक साइबर सिक्योरिटी डेनिक सर्च करेंगे
लिंडिस तरीके से कंपनी को बड़ा करते हैं
कैसे धीरे-धीरे आगे बढ़ते हैं वह सारी
जानकारी आपको यहां मिल जाएगी और यह हमारी
कंपनी का डेनिक्स का
वाले नोएडा दिल्ली ल्ली एनसीआर में तो
आपको यहां पर वो सारी अपडेट्स भी मिल
जाएंगी ठीक है
चलिए तो यहां 100 प्लस आ चुके हैं तो क्या
क्या आप बताइए मुझे आप आप जो बोलेंगे मैं
वही करूंगा पहले टॉपिक को स्टार्ट करें
बीच में हम वो ट्रीट वाला सेक्शन जो ट्रीट
वाली जो चीज है राउंड वो स्टार्ट करें या
पहले ट्रीट वाली करना है यह बता
दीजिए लेट मी
नो थैंक यू लोजन थैंक यू
लॉजस लॉट ऑफ डुप्लीकेट्स यू शुड चेंज योर
मेथड आप अपनी मेथड चेंज कीजिए डुप्लीकेट्स
आने हट जाएंगे पहले
ट्रीट ओके जो लोग इस क्लास की वीडियो की
रिकॉर्डिंग देख रहे होंगे इन फ्यूचर
फ्यूचर में उनसे मैं एक रिक्वेस्ट करता
हूं कि अ एक्सट्रीमली सॉरी ये थोड़ा सा
स्टार्टिंग का सेशन थोड़ा सा लाइक आप
स्किप कर सकते हैं अगर आप रिकॉर्डिंग देख
रहे हैं तो क्योंकि टीचर्स डे है है आज
5th सितंबर 2024 एंड यहां पे मैंने ऑलरेडी
स्टूडेंट्स को बोला था कि मेरे तरफ से एक
ट्रीट मिलेगी छोटा सा ट्रीट होगा ₹1 के
अंदर कोई भी यहां पे जितने लोग भी लाइव
में देख रहे हैं एवरीबॉडी कैन ऑर्डर
एनीथिंग कुछ भी ऑर्डर हो सकता है जरूरी
नहीं है खाने का हो या कुछ भी हो अब ₹1
में आप सोच रहे होंगे कि अरे यार ₹1 में
तो क्या ही आएगा ₹1 में क्या आ जाएगा ऐसा
तो ₹1 की बात नहीं है यहां बात यह है कि
अगर ₹1 100 कम करते हैं तो काफी ज्यादा
अमाउंट कलेक्टिव हो जाता है एक टाइम पे और
उससे ज्यादा मैं अफोर्ड नहीं कर सकता तो
मैं जितना अफोर्ड कर सकता हूं जितना ची अ
आपको अ दिला सकता हूं जिस तरीके
से वह मैं अभी आपको दिलाने वाला हूं सिंपल
सा फंडा है एंड इसीलिए मैंने अपना फोन भी
रेडी रखा है एंड आप सबसे मैं अपना यूपीआई
आईडी शेयर करूंगा ठीक है तो आप सबसे एक
रिक्वेस्ट है कि ₹1000000 के ऊपर कोई भी
चीज के लिए रिक्वेस्ट मत कीजिएगा आप
रिचार्ज कर सकते हैं ऑर्डर कर सकते हैं
कोई 100 के अंदर कुछ अगर डिलीवरी भी होती
है तो वह भी कर लीजिए कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं
है ठीक है बट 100 के नीचे 100 के ऊपर अगर
आप रिक्वेस्ट करते हैं तो मुझे मजबूरी में
कैंसिल करना पड़ जाएगा आपके रिक्वेस्ट को
ठीक है क्योंकि मैं उसको नहीं कर पाऊ ₹1
से ज्यादा आप नहीं कीजिएगा इट्स अ
रिक्वेस्ट ठीक
है तो आप सभी को समझ में आ गया होगा आप
सभी को समझ में आ गया होगा जस्ट ₹1 ठीक है
आप सभी रेडी हैं एवरीबॉडी
सॉरी प्लीज लेट मी
नो ठीक है मैं अपनी यूपी आईडी कौन सी है
मेरी
हां ठीक
है चलो मेरे लिए बाद में ऑर्डर करना अभी
फिलहाल मेरी यह जो छोटी सी गिफ्ट है उसको
एक्सेप्ट
करो मैं चैट सेक्शन को थोड़ा सा पॉप आउट
करके बड़ा कर लेता हूं ताकि सभी को चीजें
दिखती रहेंगी प्लीज स्पैम मत कीजिएगा नहीं
तो फिर मुझे मजबूरी में यह बंद करना
पड़ेगा ठीक है और जिनका ऑर्डर हो जाए तो
प्लीज आप चैट में बता दीजिएगा कि सर मेरा
ऑर्डर हो गया मेरा एक्सेप्ट मतलब मैंने
एक्सेप्ट कर लिया वो चीज ताकि लोगों को
ऐसा ना लगे कि ऐसे ही है कुछ भी ठीक है तो
प्लीज ₹ उससे ज्यादा नहीं ठीक है प्लीज
इट्स अ रिक्वेस्ट बहुत रिक्वेस्ट कर रहा
हूं मैं आपसे ठीक है चलिए तो मेरी जो
यूपीआई आईडी है मैं चैट में डाल देता हूं
यूपीआई आईडी इट्स
डि
फ्रक्स
रेट ए एक्स एल ए एक्स एल नक्स @ ए एक तो
इसको मैं पिन कर दे रहा हूं इस मैसेज को
आप सब जिसको जो ट्रीट चाहिए आप सब से एक
रिक्वेस्ट है कि आप सब रिक्वेस्ट कर सकते
हैं इस पे एंड ₹1 या ₹1 से नीचे के जो भी
ऑर्डर्स होंगे जो भी रिक्वेस्ट होंगी मैं
आपका अप्रूव कर
दूंगा ओके मेरे पास 99 का आया है जीएलए
कैंटीन के तरफ से तो मैं यहां पर एक
रिक्वेस्ट
99.2 8 का एक एक्सेप्ट कर रहा हूं प्लीज
जिनका हो जाए प्लीज बता
दीजिएगा ओके ओके 99 वाले जो है प्लीज आप
दोबारा कर दीजिए 99 वाले जो है वो दोबारा
सेंड कर दीजिए उनका शायद मेरे कुछ गलती हो
गई है यूपीआई पिन को लेके ठीक है प्लीज आप
दोबारा रिक्वेस्ट सेंड कर
दीजिएगा ओके कुछ ज्यादा ही रिक्वेस्ट आ
रही है गाइस थोड़ा धीरे की
ओके ओके मैं य पर एक 99 का फिर से ऑर्डर
कर रहा
हूं ओके सो मैंने एक 99 का जस्ट यहां पर
ऑर्डर पेमेंट सक्सेसफुल किया है तो प्लीज
आप जिसका हो जाए बता दीजिएगा जिनका
सक्सेसफुल हो जाए प्लीज जिनका सक्सेसफुल
हो जाए बता दीजिएगा एक यहां ₹ का मैं कर
रहा हूं ह का मैं कर रहा हूं दीपक करके जो
है
दीपक दीपक का हो गया है विपिन का हो गया
ग्रेट ग्रेट विपन का डन हो गया यहां पर एक
आया हुआ है मेरे पास अन
का 79 का मैं वोह कर रहा हूं आई हैव दीपक
का हो गया चलिए डन थैंक यू ओके दीपक बहुत
अच्छा अने आपका हो
गया ओके दो बार मत कीजिएगा कोई भी जोमेटो
से किसी का ऑर्डर है 95 का 95 का 95 पैसे
का जोमेटो से ऑर्डर है तो मैंने जोमेटो
वाला अप्रूव कर दिया है मैंने जोमेटो वाला
मतलब पे कर दिया है ठीक है जोमेटो वाले
कौन से ये कौन
सा ओके यहां पे जील ग्रोफर्स का कोई ऑर्डर
है यह मैंने ग्रोफर्स का तो कर दिया था अन
पे अन पे वाला भी मैंने कर दिया
था
ओके ओके मेरे पास काफी सारे रिक्वेस्ट आ
रहे हैं गाइस यहां पर आया
है मशो मीशो का आया हुआ है मेरे पास तो
मैं मीशो गाइस कुछ ज्यादा फास्ट आ रही है
मेरे पास रिक्वेस्ट तो थोड़ा सा थोड़ा सा
वेट कीजिएगा मीशो का मैंने किया है
रिक्वेस्ट अप्रूव किया है मिशो वाला जो भी
है भैया उसका छोटू कुमार है कोई छोटू
कुमार तो छोटू कुमार का मैंने गिफ्ट जो है
अप्रूव कर दिया है हैप्पी टीचर्स डे यह
टीचर्स डे के के लिए मेरे साइड से आप सबको
एक छोटी सी भेट है आप बोल सकते हैं
ओके यह पॉपअप कहां गया ओके ओके आप लोग आप
लोग आप लोग किसी को बता सकते हो ऐसे किसी
को वीडियो शेयर कर सकते हो कि भैया ऐसी
चीजें हो रही है यहां पे आप किसी को
वीडियो शेयर कर सकते हो यह लाइव ताकि लाइव
हमारा पॉपुलर हो जाए लाइव चारों तरफ फैल
जाए ओके अरे यूपीआई आईडी दिया है यूपीआई
आईडी ऊपर पिन किया है उस परे कोई भी चीज
पेमेंट कर सकते हो 100 के नीचे रिक्वेस्ट
कर सकते हो मैं अप्रूव करूंगा ठीक है तो
यहां पे पहले के जो रिक्वेस्ट हैं वो
रिक्वेस्ट थोड़े जपटो से ऑर्डर किया है
किसी ने जेप्टो से किया है तो जेप्टो वाला
आप लोग अपना ऑर्डर करके थोड़ी देर तक वेट
कीजिएगा और उसी पेज पर वेट कीजिएगा जब भी
आप ऑर्डर कर देंगे उस थोड़ी देर के लिए
वेट कीजिएगा ठीक है वहां से हटिए मत नहीं
तो एक्सपायर हो जाएगा यह कौन है भाई गौरव
का स्विगी का कितने रुपए का है भाई
7464 7464 का स्विगी का किसका है
भाई 7464 वाली एक् कहां है रिक्वेस्ट कौन
थी कौन है भाई 7464
स्विगी वाले खाने वाले यार मेरे पास तो
कहीं दिखा नहीं रहा है चलो 102 का किसी का
है मैं 102 वाला जोमेटो का है खाने का दो
रुप ज्यादा है उस बेचारे के तो मैंने दो
रप ज्यादा उसके कर दिए लेकिन ऐसा मत करना
आगे मैं यार ख खोज नहीं सकता किगी एक
स्विगी का 93 का है किसी का मैं स्विगी का
93 का ओके ऑलरेडी पेमेंट हो चुका है इसका
तो मैं इसको नहीं कर रहा ठीक
है सॉरी सॉरी बहुत ज्यादा रिक्वेस्ट आ रही
है गाइस तो थोड़ा सा हैंडल करना मुश्किल
हो रहा है बट हो जाएगा जस्ट
वेट एक जोमट का स्विगी का एक 98 स्विगी का
एक 72 का है तो मैं 72 वाला कर रहा
हूं जिसका इसका हो जाए भाई हो हो जा कर
रहा हूं स्विगी
का ओके 98 का हो
[संगीत]
गया
ओके काफी ज्यादा रिक्वेस्ट आ गई है गाइस अ
कंफर्म कर दीजिए हो गया गुड गुड गुड गुड
ये कौन है भाई स्विगी का ये कौन है भाई
अरे यार ऐसे देखूंगा तब तो बोलेंगे लोग कि
देख देख के कर रहे हैं मैं यहां से रैंडम
कर रहा हूं ना शोएब शोएब का ₹ का है शोएब
लियाकत तो सोब लियाकत
जी मैंने आपका कर दिया 100 का ठीक
है क्या चल रहा है भाई बताओ उसको कोई क्या
चल रहा है मैं मैं कैसे बताऊं पता है 38
रिक्वेस्ट है अभी यार मैं कैसे करूंगा
इतना मतलब जल्दी जल्दी 137 का किसी ने
किया मैं वो नहीं कर सकता 137 वाला तो
नहीं करूंगा भाई मैं मैंने पहले ही बोला
था ओके एक और किया है मैंने पेमेंट एंड यह
पेमेंट है 9 का सोमेश करके नाम है इनका तो
देख लीजिएगा सोमेश जी आपका हो चुका है
पेमेंट j का कोई प्रीपेड रिचार्ज है उसी
पेज पर रहिएगा जो जो रिचार्ज वाला कर रहे
हैं उसी पेज पे रहेंगे तभी नहीं तो वो हो
जाएगा जो ऑलरेडी पैसे वाले भाई ये ये है
वो बस टोकन ऑफ
एप्रिसिएशन चलो थोड़ी देर तक वेट कर लो
थोड़ी देर तक रिक्वेस्ट भेजना बंद कर दो
गाइस ताकि मैं सभी के रिक्वेस्ट को यहां
पे अप्रूव कर पाऊं भेजोगे तो होगा नहीं एक
बर्गर किंग का है 03 का कौन है भाई बर्गर
किंग का बर्गर किंग के नाम से मेरे मुंह
में पानी आ गया आई लव बर्गर
किंग चलो यहां पर बर्गर किंग वाला हो गया
स्विगी का 133 का रिचार्ज मैं रिजेक्ट कर
देता हूं मैं यह नहीं करूंगा प्लीज इट्स
रिक्वेस्ट प्लीज डोंट प्लीज डोंट डू मोर
देन 100 प्लीज इट्स रिक्वेस्ट एटेल का
पेमेंट्स का है रिचार्ज का तो चलिए एटेल
के पेमेंट का रिचार्ज कर देते
हैं ओके कितने लोग अभी है ऑनलाइन ऑनलाइन
काफी 147 लोग ऑनलाइन आ चुके हैं क्या बात
है ये अच्छी बात है और भी कोई
है निधि निधि तिवार र 20 का क्या बात है
भाई 20
का यह अच्छी बात है 20 का किया है चलो यह
अच्छी बात है मेरा भी ध्यान रख रहे हैं
लोग और कोई है
क्या भाई बहुत ज्यादा रिक्वेस्ट आ रही है
मैं क्या बोलू मैं समझ नहीं आ रहा गला
कैंटीन 97 का 97 23 पैसे इनका हो नहीं
पाया था पिछली बार तो मैं गला कैंटीन जो
भी है जीएलए कैंटीन या गला कैंटीन
उनका नहीं 146 का मैं नहीं कर पाऊंगा
प्लीज प्लीज डोंट डू दैट प्लीज डोंट डू
दैट मैं किसी का नहीं कर रहा 101 102 हो
चलेगा बट अब 150 से 146 130 ऐसे करोगे तो
फिर दिक्कत हो जाएगी यार ठी ऐसे मत करो
प्लीज यार इट्स अ रिक्वेस्ट यहां पे बंडल
टेक्नोलॉजीज करके कुछ है तो मैं यहां पे
पेमेंट कर देता
हूं याद रखिएगा
यह पेमेंट रिक्वेस्ट आप कर रहे हैं थैंक्स
भैया हो गया चलो अच्छी बात है जिसका हो
गया भाई एक बार हेलो बोल के जाना स्विगी
इं माट से 117 का कर रहा है कोई 117 का
मैं नहीं करूंगा लेकिन इसका कर दे रहा हूं
17 का अगले बार से मत भेजना प्लीज अगले
बार से मत भेजना इस बार तो कर दिया है
क्योंकि स्विगी का है पता नहीं उसको खाने
का कुछ मन होगा बट अगली बार से कोई मत
करना मैं नहीं करूंगा लिटरली नहीं करूंगा
जोमट 97.3 ये यार 97 33 में जोमेटो में
क्या है यार बार-बार आ रहा
है हो गया मंक चलिए अच्छी बात है मंग जी
का हो गया
तो हो गया भाई क्या बात है गुड गुड गुड
गुड गुड हो गया
ना अभी स्विगी से 55 का आया है अच्छी बात
है स्विगी से 55 का आया
है ओके तो 55 वाला हो गया 55 वाला हो गया
जिसका नहीं हो पाया भाई वो गुस्सा मत करना
नाराज म मत हो जाना यार ठीक है नाराज मत
हो जाना प्लीज और एक बंदा एक ही बार करना
यार बाकी लोगों को भी थोड़ा वो करने देना
हेमंत शाहू
87 हो गया धन्यवाद भाई चलो अच्छी बात है
आपका हो गया
तो स्विगी का 105 का यह स्विगी वाले 1005
का मैं कर देता हूं पता नहीं भूख लगी होगी
उसको भाई को भूख लगी होगी तो भूख को मार
नहीं सकते ज्यादा अब 105 भूख को नहीं मार
सकते इसका मतलब ये नहीं कि 200 का कर देना
ठीक
है वो फिर भूख को मारना पड़ेगा आपको जोमट
का 104 का कर दे रहा हूं 104 का पेमेंट
एक्सेप्ट कर लिया
मैंने यह मैंने चैट इसलिए खोल के रखा ना
आप लोग कम से कम बोलिएगा कि हो जा रहा है
आपका हो रहा है आपका लाइट एटलीस्ट
jio9apps ओके यहां मैंने कर दिया ओके ओके
ओके बहुत बढ़िया अ चलिए 143 का मैं नहीं
कर रहा एक्सट्रीमली सॉरी अन बिल पे अरे
बिल पे 99 का क्या बात है चलो इनका बिल
पेमेंट कर देते हैं किसी का बिल पेमेंट है
99 का उनका बिल पेमेंट ये कैसे ये बचा के
रखा क्या भाई मेरे लिए बिल पेमेंट अच्छा
कुकू एफएम का लिया है किसी ने
सब्सक्रिप्शन शायद क्या बात है यार मेरे
से कुकू एफएम का सब्सक्रिप्शन ले रहे हो
भाई
ग्रोफर्स
94 अरे मेरे को मेरा बैलेंस भी चेक करना
पड़ेगा लग रहा है अब मेरे को बैलेंस चेक
करना
पड़ेगा क्या बताऊं आउट ऑफ कयो सिटी मरने
वाले हो तो क्या बताऊं यह तो बताओ क्या
बताऊं मैं उधर ध्यान नहीं दे रहा ज्यादा
गुरु दक्षिणा 101 सेंट क्या बात है किसी
ने 01 मुझे भी भेजे हैं थैंक यू सो मच
थैंक यू सो मच 01 मुझे भेजने के लिए किसने
भेजा है भरत सिंह अच्छा भरत सिंह हमारे
स्टूडेंट है मुझ मैं जानता हूं भरत सिंह
को तो इतने सारी उसमें आप आपने मुझे अगर
रप रप भेजे हैं तो एक्सट्रीमली थैंक यू
फॉर योर जनर सिटी उसको मैं गिफ्ट एक्सेप्ट
करता हूं ठीक
है ठीक है बहुत सारी रिक्वेस्ट आ रही है
भाई रुक जाओ यार थोड़ी देर रुक जाओ भाई
भाई थोड़ी देर रुक जाओ मल्टीपल टाइम वाले
मत करो प्लीज इट्स रिक्वेस्ट मल्टीपल टाइम
एक बार मत
करो थोड़ा नीचे की तरफ चलते हैं कैलाश 6 5
कैलास जिनका जो आप रिक्वेस्ट कर रहे हैं
ना आप उस पेमेंट पेज पर ही रुकिए हटा मत
दीजिएगा पेमेंट पेज को अदर वाइज वो कैंसिल
हो जाएगा आपका ठीक है मैंने यहां पर कैलास
एस का कर दिया है
पेमेंट एटेल पेमेंट्स का दो मिनट पहले आया
था आई डोंट नो य वैलिड वैलिड तो होगा
क्योंकि अभी भी पेमेंट हो रहा है तो एटेल
पेमेंटस का मैंने कर दिया
ये ठीक है जिनका जिनका हो रहा है
भाई वह सब खुश हो गए हैं बहुत ज्यादा दीपक
जी फिर से रिक्वेस्ट कर रहे हैं ये दीपक
देखो दो बार मत करो दीपक मुझे तुम्हारा
नाम याद है दीपक दीपक दो बार रिक्वेस्ट कर
रहा है ये ऐसे नहीं चलेगा एक बार करो कोई
एक बंदा एक ही बार करेगा नहीं तो फिर नहीं
हो
पाएगा ठीक है और यह ग्रोफर्स के बार-बार
मत करो यार प्लीज यह बार-बार एक ही बंदा
जो कर रहा है ना वो सही नहीं है
कहानियां सुननी
होंगी तो इनका कर देते हैं हो गया सूरज
महतो अच्छी बात है हो गया तो अच्छी बात है
कोई यार काम की चीज कुछ ढंग की चीज अगर हो
तो वो भी कर लेना सही
रहेगा जिओ जिओ j j j j j j j j j ऐसे
ग्रोफर
स्विगी j का प्रीपेड रिचार्ज आया
है हां प्रीपेड रिचार्ज मैं कर दूंगा
प्रीपेड रिचार्ज मैं कर रहा हूं ठीक है
न मिनट में अप्रूवल टाइम आउट क्या किया यह
तो बता दो न मिनट में अप्रूवल अमित
बेनीवाल नाम से करोगे तो ज्यादा ज्यादा
इजी हो जाएगा आप लोग पता नहीं कहां से कर
रहे
हो अच्छा मेटा से भी रिक्वेस्ट कर लिया
क्या ठीक है मेटा से मैं ह र का कर दे रहा
हूं आई डोंट नो मेटा से क्या है यह बट
लेट्स ड ह
मेटा 155 का रिचार्ज नहीं कर पाऊंगा ब्रदर
एक्सट्रीमली
सॉरी मोहम्मद
आपका मैं यहां से मोहम्मद शेख आपका मैं 99
का कर रहा हूं मोहम्मद
शेख बजट बजट का मुझे नहीं पता बजट मुझे
मेरा कुछ नहीं है र तक का है फिलहाल बस
यही है बजट का तो कुछ है नहीं मोहम्मद का
हो गया मोहम्मद जी
आपका ओके अरे भाई एक बार में यह जीएलए
कैंटीन और यह सब बारबार करोगे तो मैं नहीं
करूंगा एक्सेप्ट सच बता रहा हूं मैं यह
बारबार जी कैंटीन से कर रहा है बंदा 217
का स्वी नहीं हो पाएगा
अनीता नाम से कोई है पूरा नाम मैं नहीं
बोलूंगा ओनली शॉर्ट नेम तो उनका मैं
अप्रूव कर रहा हूं ओके ट्रांजैक्शन फेल हो
गया इनका पता नहीं ट्रांजेक्शन फेल क्यों
हु ह का सफायर फूड्स 104 का चलिए सफायर
फूड 104 का मैं कर देता हूं और यूपीआई में
भी शायद कुछ लिमिट होती है ना एक दिन का
अभी तो नहीं हुआ लिमिट
हो ऋतु उपाध्याय 91 जिओ रिचार्ज 91 जिओ
रिचार्ज 91 का j रिचार्ज कहां है भाई मे
तो j से कहीं 91 का दिख नहीं रहा
यार j 69 तो
है j 29
है j j j j का 99 का तो कुछ है ही नहीं
यार j का 29 है यार पता नहीं इतने ज्यादा
रिक्वेस्ट आ रहे हैं कि वो थोड़ी देर के
बाद भी रिक्वेस्ट पीछे चले जा रहे हैं रुक
जाओ देख लेता हूं मैं j का यार मुझे कहीं
मिल नहीं रहा मैं ज्यादा नीचे जा नहीं
सकता ज्यादा नीचे जा नहीं सकता
कर
दिया ओके 99 डन और भी देख लेते हैं यहां
पे चलिए य बार-बार आप रिक्वेस्ट जो कर रहे
हैं ना तो इस वजह से दिक्कत आ रही है
बार-बार रिक्वेस्ट मत कीजिए आप बार-बार
रिक्वेस्ट करेंगे तो मैं यहां से एक्सेप्ट
नहीं कर पाऊंगा उसको क्योंकि मेरे को समझ
में आ जा रहा है कि कौन मल्टीपल टाइम्स कर
रहा है मिस्टर रोशन कुमार 93 आई डोंट नो
93 क्या है बट स्टिल मैं यहां पर एक्सेप्ट
करता
हूं मयंक तिवारी अभी तक र नहीं आया पता
नहीं यार मैंने नहीं किया होगा ना यहां से
फिर तभी नहीं आ होगा 20 मुझे दिख ही नहीं
रहा तो जो दिख रहा है मैं कर रहा
हूं जपटो का है 103
का जपटो का करते हैं 103
का काफी लोगों ने लगता है वीडियो काफी जगह
शेयर कर दिया मुझे लगता
है 163 लोग आए हैं अभी यहां पे वीडियो पे
जेप्टो वाली डिक्लाइन हो गई क्योंकि
जेप्टो वाली डिक्लाइन हो गई है क्योंकि आई
थिंक थोड़ा यूपीआई पिन डालने में गलत हो
गया है फिर से आप रिक्वेस्ट कर दीजिएगा
पार्थ करके 99 का है मैं पार्थ का 99 का
कर रहा हूं किसी का डिक्लाइन अगर हो जाए
गलती से तो समझिए यूपीआई पिन के थोड़ी
बहुत मिस्टेक्स हुई होगी दोबारा आप
रिक्वेस्ट कर लीजिएगा तो वो सही
चलेगा सब स्विगी अरे बाप रे स्विगी और
ग्रोफर्स की और
इन सब की तो बैंड बजा दी तुम लोगों ने इन
लोग यह सोच इतना ऑर्डर ऐसे छोटे छोटे का
कैसे आ रहा है भाई ₹ का किया है मैंने ₹
का मैंने किया
है 93 18 है किसका मृदुल का मैंने किया र
का 93 18 किसका है भाई 93
18 93
18 93 18 93 18 किसका है भाई मुझे दिखे
भाई बहुत तेजी से रिक्वेस्ट ऊपर नीचे हो र
है 93 का मुझे कहीं दिख नहीं
रहा 931
931 आई डोंट नो 93 निधि नवर निधि तिवार र
मैंने कर दिया था यार इनका तो बट स्टिल
मैं दोबारा 20 आई थिंक य मेरे कोर्स का ही
कर रहे
य कालपी थैंक यू सर ओके आपका हो
गया ओके मेरा बैलेंस चेक करना पड़ेगा लग
रहा है कुछ ज्यादा ही मैंने कर दिया है
पेमेंट तो मैं बैलेंस चेक कर लू एक बार
तुम लोग मेरे को कहीं कंगाल ना कर दो यार
ऐसे करते
करते ओ भाई गजब गजब बहुत ज्यादा हो गए
काफी हो गए बट ठीक है
स्टिल आपको पता है बहुत सारे पेमेंट्स हो
चुके हैं अभी तक बहुत सारे पेमेंट हो चुके
हैं चलो थोड़े पेमेंट्स और लेते हैं थोड़े
और लेते हैं पेमेंटस ठीक है फिर स्टार्ट
करते हैं क्लास आज जो रिकॉर्डिंग देख रहे
होंगे ना आज की क्लास की बोल रहे होंगे
अरे भाई ये क्या हो रहा है ये
भाई अरे यार यह गजब ही मतलब कुछ ज्यादा
रिक्वेस्ट आ रही है
यार जोमेटो एक्सेप्ट करो पार्थ
नारला अच्छा आप लोग अपना अपना अमाउंट
बताते जाइए जिस अमाउंट के लिए आप लोग
रिक्वेस्ट कर रहे हैं आप लोग अमाउंट बताइए
j 69 चलो एक j का 69 का आया है मेरे
पास j 69 जो था ना भाई उसका हुआ क्या
बताना जरा अमन सिंह मैंने एक 69 वाला किया
है j 69 अमन सिंह आपका
हुआ अब देखो इतने मैसेज आ रहे हैं कि पता
नहीं
चलेगा अरे रुक जाओ भाई अमन सिंह का हो गया
ना
भाई ऋतु उपाध्याय 91 जियो रिचार्ज 91 ऋतु
उपाध्याय 91 में ऋतु उपाध्याय जिओ रिचार्ज
अरे यार तुम्हारा मिल क्यों नहीं रहा भाई
मुझे 91 में ऋतु उपाद
जि 91 का मुझे दिख तो जाए
पहले अन बिल पे है एक अन बिल पे है एक 91
का चलो यह कर देते हैं 91 का अन का बिल पे
है पता नहीं इसी से किया हो
रिचार्ज चलो एक 91 का मैंने पेमेंट किया
यहां
पर आई डोंट
नो रुक जाओ भाई रुक जाओ रुक जाओ 105 119
92 100 बाप रे बाप 99 का किसका है भाई
अ j का एक 69 का है किसी
का किसी का नहीं है
ना ये तो हो गया था यार j का 69
का ऑटो पे रिक्वेस्ट डाल र है कोई अब बताओ
यार ऑटो पे रिक्वेस्ट डालोगे तब तो मैं
नहीं करूंगा ना ऑटो पे एक बंदा ऑटो पे
रिक्वेस्ट डाल रहा है
बताओ ये कौन है
ऑटो पर रिक्वेस्ट वाला इसका मैं डिक्लाइन
कर देता हूं अब बताओ यार ऐसे चलेगा
क्या ऑटो पर मत डालो फिर कोई फायदा नहीं
है व
आपका ठीक है ओके स्विगी का 96 का है
कोई स्विगी 96 मैं कर रहा हूं आईम डूइंग
स्विगी
96 29 कौन है भाई 29 यार भाई जिनका नहीं
हो रहा है ना
थोड़ा टेंशन ज्यादा मत
लो माफ करो क्योंकि बहुत सारे आ रहे हैं
मेरे पास एमन का एक 59 का है चलो अन 59 कर
रहा हूं मैं अन का 59 का जिसका जिसका हो
जाए बता देना भाई हो जा रहा है मेरे पास
रिक्वेस्ट पता है कितने अभी यह पॉसिबल ही
नहीं है सारे हो जाए 90 रिक्वेस्ट है तुम
समझ रहे हो 90 ठीक है अमन का है एक 69 का
एक 69 का है अमन
का वो मैंने कर
दिया ठीक है ये मैंने 69 का कर दिया जल्दी
हो जा
भाई ओके 69 हो जा
भाई अभी भी यह वो हो रहा है देख लो अभी
प्रोसेसिंग हो रही है 69 वाली यहां पे
प्रोसेसिंग हो रही है य मैं दिखा भी देता
हूं शायद तुम्हें ऐसा ना लग रहा हो कि पता
नहीं क्या तो यह 69 का दिख रहा होगा सबको
पता नहीं दिख रहा है कि नहीं आई डोंट नो
बट ही है ठीक है अभी भी ये प्रोसेस हो रहा
है 69
वाला ओके गाइस आई थिंक काफी सारे हमने
ट्रीट दे दिए लोगों को काफी लोगों
को ठीक है काफी लोगों को काफी ट्रीट दे
दिया है ₹ अभी मेरा तो कोई सा भी नहीं हो
रहा अभी तो देख रहा हूं
मैं खाने वालों का ज्यादा मैंने एक्सेप्ट
थोड़ा जल्दी जल्दी किया था
ताकि उनका खाने का काम हो जाए बट यह खाने
वाले का कुछ ज्यादा ही रिक्वेस्ट मेरे पास
आया है बहुत ज्यादा फिजिक्स वाले का 99
फिजिक्स वाले का 99 अगर कर रहे हैं तो मैं
फिजिक्स वाला का कर दे रहा हूं क्योंकि
शायद किसी के पढ़ने का कुछ होगा कुछ स्टडी
का कुछ होगा तो मैं इसको प्रायोरिटी पर कर
रहा हूं फिजिक्स वाला का परमिंदर सिंह र
मुझे दिया उन्होंने थैंक यू सो मच परमिंदर
जी जोमेटो का रेजर पे का है 9.83 जोमट
9.83 मैंने वो पेमेंट कर दिया
है 83 हो चुका है जोमट 9.83 हो चुका
है कोई बात नहीं भाई फेक आईडी साहब आपकी
भी तो हो गई थी तो आप थोड़ा वेट कर लीजिए
बस नकुम
96 96 का हो रहा है नकुम 96 का आपका मैंने
कर
[संगीत]
दिया उसके बाद स्विगी का एक 92 का किसी का
है तो मैं का 92 का कर रहा
हूं ओके स्विगी 92 डन खाने वालों का मैं
थोड़ा प्रायोरिटी पर कर रहा हूं यह याद
रखिएगा स्विगी 106 चलो 106 वाले का कर
देते हैं कुछ कुछ खाने का कुछ कर देते हैं
इनका काफी ज्यादा था वैसे बट स्टिल रंग
यूपीआई पिन आ गया 106 पे 106 वाले दोबारा
कर लीजिएगा इट्स रिक्वेस्ट 106 वाले जो है
दोबारा कर लीजिएगा
रिक्वेस्ट उसको कैंसिल करके तो यहां पर
फिर मैं ट्राई करूंगा क्योंकि
वो गलत कैंसिल हो गया
वो ओके जोमेटो 99.8 अगेन दोबारा ये 99.3
का रिक्वेस्ट आ रहा है तो मैं नहीं करूंगा
ये दो बार अगर एक ही रिक्वेस्ट आएगी एक ही
अमाउंट की तो मैं नहीं करूंगा फोन पे
₹ निशांत निशांत नाम का है कोई 0 का फोन
पे पे है तो वो मैं कर दे रहा
हूं डन कर दिया मैंने चलिए काफी सारी
ऑलरेडी हो चुकी है यहां पे स्विगी का 106
का अभी आ गया दोबारा तो मैं दोबारा 106
वाले का दोबारा कर देता हूं इनका कैंसिल
हो गया था तो मैंने 106 हो गया भैया आयुष
गुप्ता 106 स्विगी हो चुका आपका बताइए जरा
आयुष 106 स्विगी मैंने अभी जस्ट अप्रूव
किया बताइए अगर आपका हो गया है तो इज इट
डन
आयुष आयुष आपका
हुआ मुझे बता दीजिए एक बार 106 मैंने अभी
किया
चलिए अच्छी बात है हो गया तो अच्छी बात है
ग्रेट 106 का मैंने अभी किया था जस्ट 106
का आई डोंट नो स् मैंने 106 का भी पता
नहीं किसका किया है लेकिन 106 का भी
दोबारा एक और आया है तो मैं एक और कर देता
हूं नहीं इसका तो हो चुका है 106 का तो
मैंने कर दिया इसका बोल रहा यूव ऑलरेडी
मेड पेमेंट
बर्गर किंग का 103 का है स्विगी का किसी
का मैं 103 का कर देता
हूं चलिए सो गाइस आई थिंक इट्स
क्वाइट डन नाउ आई थिंक हमारा जो काम था वह
हो चुका है काफी सारे पैसे उड़ा दिए आप
लोगों ने मेरे बहुत मेहनत से पैसे यह कमाए
होते हैं बट स्टिल मैंने आपको खुद ही
ट्रीट दिया है मुझे पता है तो मैं आपको
कुछ बोल नहीं रहा जस्ट थिंक की अब हो चुका
है बहुत जदा हो चुका रहने दो भाई काफी
सारे अभी भी मेरे पास रिक्वेस्ट पड़े हैं
इतना रिक्वेस्ट तो मैं कभी वैसे भी नहीं
कर सकता क्योंकि 90 प्लस 100 होने वाले
रिक्वेस्ट वैसे तो 100 के आसपास रिक्वेस्ट
है एंड इतना रिक्वेस्ट नहीं कर सकते हैं
मतलब एक्सेप्ट तो कर ही नहीं सकते
इंपॉसिबल है राइट तो इसके लिए एक्सट्रीमली
सॉरी जिनका जिनका नहीं हुआ है उसके लिए
उनको एक्सट्रीमली सॉरी पहले ही मैं बोल
देता हूं जिनका हो गया है मस्ती से खाओ
एंजॉय करो तुम्हारा आज दिन था मजे करने का
चलो एक दो और ले लेते हैं एक दो और
रिक्वेस्ट ले लेते
हैं फ मिनट्स मोर एंड कर देते हैं बंच
माइक्रो टेक्नोलॉजी वाह वाह यह मेरा ही
कोर्स 000 का कर रहा है भाई वो तो पॉसिबल
नहीं है फिजिक्स वाला का एक और आया है
मेरे पास मैं फिजिक्स वाले का कर दे रहा
हूं यह मेरे कोर्स को मत खरीदो मेरे से
यार 000 में पेमेंट नहीं कर नहीं करूंगा
सॉरी यह फिजिक्स वाला का पिन गलत हो गया
फिर से दोबारा भेज दो भाई वाले का पिन गलत
हो
गया जोमेटो का 99.5 जोमेटो
99.5 99.5 जोमेटो डन अमित बेनीवाल अमित
बेनीवाल बताइए आपका हो गया अमित अमित
बेनीवाल कंफर्म कर दीजिए एक बार अमित
बेनीवाल आपका मैंने कर दिया 99.5 हो गया
आपका बताइए
यार जिसका हो जा रहा है ना वो भाग जा रहा
है यार थैंक यू सर अच्छा चलिए बढ़िया बात
है हो जा हो गया मतलब फिजिक्स वाले का फिर
से एक आया
है द पेमेंट रिक्वेस्ट पेमेंट रिक्वेस्ट
एक्सपायर्ड आपका दिखा रहा है फिजिक्स वाले
का यार तुम लोग काफी ज्यादा महंगे महंगे
आइटम्स मंगा रहे हो कहां-कहां से यार क्या
बात
है चलो जोमट का एक 86 का कर रहे
हैं 8 6.06 का कर रहे हैं
8608 का कर रहे जट
का ठीक है कर दिया
मैंने एक एक और भाई साहब
है स्विगी का 84 र का चलो स्विगी का 84 का
कर
दिया स् का 84 का कर
दिया जो मैं नितेश कुमार सिंह
यह कौन है भाई 99 का एक्सेप्ट कर
रिक्वेस्ट कर रहा है यह मेरा ही मेरा ही
नेम है इस पर तो पता नहीं
यार र का मिस्टर सोमेश र का 20 का इनका कर
देते हैं
पेमेंट 20 का पेमेंट कर रहे हम य
पर
धन्यवाद चलिए गाइस
ओके काफी सारी रिक्वेस्ट आ चुकी है यहां
पर काफी सारी रिक्वेस्ट मेरे को देख रहे
हैं मेरे को दिख रहे हैं यहां पर काफी
ज्यादा रिक्वेस्ट आ रही है मैं ज्यादा
नहीं कर सकता एक्सट्रीमली
सॉरी यहां पर रप का एक स्विगी का
रिक्वेस्ट आया
है मनसुख भाया जी मनसुख मा जीी फिजिक्स
वाला का एक 99 का रिक्वेस्ट आया है चलिए
फिजिक्स वाला 99 रिक्वेस्ट एक्सेप्ट कर
लेते
हैं अमन सिंह का हो गया 9733 जोमेटो
जोमेटो 97.3
स्विगी का एक ₹ का आया है इनको भूख लगी
होगी इनको कर देते
हैं स्विगी काफी यूज कर रहे हो यार मैं
देख नहीं चैट नहीं देख पा रहा एक्सट्रीमली
सॉरी मैं यहां पर फटाफट कर ले रहा
[संगीत]
हूं और भी कोई है
क्या सफायर फूड से पहले भी आया था तो मैं
दोबारा नहीं करूंगा
इसको ओके बंच माइक्रो टेक्नोलॉजी
₹ वाले यह कर देते
हैं ठीक है यह वाला हो गया यह हमारे कोर्स
का ही है अ
तो j का मैं 69.5 का कर दे रहा
हूं रिसोर्सेस के लिए आप रिक्वेस्ट कर लो
कोई दिक्कत नहीं
है मंच माइक्रो टेक्नोलॉजी का 20 53 पैसा
इसका इसका मैं कर दे रहा हूं
एक्सेप्ट मंच वाला तो हो गया जो भी था जो
₹ वाली कोर्स वाले जिन्होंने किए थे का
मैंने कर दिया
है ठीक है सो 107 का जो मेटो का है किसी
का तो मैं 107 जोमट कर दे रहा हूं एंड
दैट्ची कर रहा बट स्टिल मैंने रिक्वेस्ट
लेना छोड़ दिया है तो आप लोग प्लीज डोंट
सेंड द रिक्वेस्ट आप सबसे एक रिक्वेस्ट है
कि डोंट सेंड द रिक्वेस्ट आप सबसे एक
रिक्वेस्ट है कि डोंट सेंड द रिक्वेस्ट
ठीक है बस इतना ही बोलूंगा मैं फोकस मोड
चालू कर दिया मैंने ताकि कोई डिस्टरबेंस
ना हो अपनी क्लास के बीच में और आज की जो
क्लास है उसको स्टार्ट कर लेते हैं
क्योंकि काफी टाइम हो गया थैंक यू सो मच
एवरी बडी फॉर जॉइनिंग
दिस सिंपल ट्रीट फ्रॉम माय साइड छोटा सा
ट्रीट था मेरे साइड से आप सबके लिए आई होप
कि आपको अच्छा लगा होगा अब मुझे ईमानदारी
से मुझे ईमानदारी से बता दीजिए ईमानदारी
से बताइएगा कि आप में से कितने लोग ऐसे
हैं यहां पर जिनको यह ट्रीट मिल गई है
जिनको मिली है नहीं मिली वो छोड़ दीजिएगा
जिनको मिली है वो कौन-कौन है जिनको मिल गई
है वो एक बार बता
दीजिए जिनको मिल गई है वह बता दीजिए जिनको
बस मिली है वह बताइएगा हिमांशु मिल गई
हिमांशु को मिल गया है ठीक है दीपक को मिल
गया है शिव को मिल गया है मयंक को मिल गया
है
हिस्ट्री फैक्ट को मिला
ओके श्रीनिवास को मिला है ओके काफी लोगों
को मिल गया काफी लोगों को मिला है ट्स
ग्रेट ट्स ग्रेट गाइस ट्स ग्रेट एंड
कांग्रेचुलेशन आप सबको कि आप सबको यह जो
बेसिकली अवार्ड है एक तरह से या एक तरह से
ट्रीट है टीचर्स डे प वो मेरे साइड से आप
सबके लिए था छोटा सा ट्रीट था जिनको नहीं
मिला एक्सट्रीमली सॉरी मैं बहुत ज्यादा
अभी भी 100 प्लस रिक्वेस्ट है मैं उतना
नहीं कर सकता हूं क्योंकि मैंने पहले ही
बोला था कि एक यह ट्रीट है तो इसको एज
ट्रीट समझिए इसको ऐसा मत समझिए कि मुझे
नहीं मिला सर मैं मुझे मुझे क्यों नहीं
मिला सर सुपर चैट क्यों नहीं हो रही है
पता नहीं मुझे सुपर चैट क्यों नहीं हो रही
है आई डोंट नो सुपर चैट तो नॉर्मली हो
जाती है कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है ठीक है तो
थैंक यू सो मच एवरीबॉडी फॉर जॉइनिंग दिस
एंड लेट्स स्टार्ट द सेशन
चलिए अ कितना खर्च हुआ आई थिंक अ
अ 4000 के आसपास जो है खर्च हुए होंगे खल
से जहां तक मुझे लग रहा है जो मैंने देखा
था
अभी 4500 का खर्च हुआ है लगभग 4500 का ठीक
है मुझे 107 किसने भेजा है
मुझे मुझे मेरे पास कुछ पैसे आए हैं 107
99 यह कौन से आ गए हैं आई डोंट नो कुछ
रिफंड्स भी आ गए हैं क्या मेरे पास मेरे
पास कुछ रिफंड्स आ गए शायद जिनके कुछ
पेमेंट की गड़बड़ी हुई होगी उनके कुछ
रिफंड्स मेरे पास आ गए होंगे तो प्लीज
डोंट माइंड बट बाकी काफी लोगों के जो हो
गए हैं ओ माय गॉड कुछ ज्यादा ही रिकॉर्ड
बन गया अभी हमने पेमेंट का
हमने कितने पेमेंट किए आपको आप सोच भी
नहीं सकते पता है कितने पेमेंट किए हैं यू
कैन जस्ट
इमेजिन 1 दोती 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14
15 16 17 18 19 20 21 22 2 25 26 27 28 29
30 31 32
लगभग 90 लगभग 90 पेमेंट हमने किया यानी कि
लगभग 90 लोगों को यहां पर मिला है
ऑलमोस्ट लगभग 90 पेमेंट हमने किए
चलिए अच्छा खासा लगे 5000 अप्रॉक्स मान के
चलो अप्रॉक्स
5000 ठीक है जल्दी टीच एम ट्रा हकमी के
गिव अवे का वाउचर जल्दी आ जाएगा ठीक है सो
जिन लोगों का जोमेटो स्विगी वगैरह हुआ
होगा एंजॉय द फूड साथ में क्लास में आ
जाइए साथ में क्लास भी आप एंजॉय कीजिए फूड
के साथ जिनका रिचार्ज हुआ है आप लोग का जो
भी डाटा वगैरह है व रिचार्ज हो गया है तो
आप लोग अब रिचार्ज का लुत्फ उठाइए तो आज
की जो क्लास है आज की जो सेशन है वह काफी
एक इंटरेस्टिंग सेशन है मैं आपको थोड़ा
समझाता हूं सेशन के बारे में आ जाइए इसपे
एमएफए
और 2 एफ ठीक है मिस
कॉन्फिन मिस कॉन्फिन अब इसका मतलब क्या है
इसमें हम क्या देखने वाले हैं मैं पहले
आपको वही बता देता हूं एमएफए का मतलब आप
सबको पता होना चाहिए मल्टी
फैक्टर
ऑथेंटिकेशन ठीक है मल्टी फैक्टर
ऑथेंटिकेशन के अंदर ही आपका ट एए वगैरह आ
जाता है क्यूआर लाइक ऑथेंटिकेटर
googlethalli.com लगाते हैं ना 2 एए के
फॉर्म में या कोई अ
googlethalli.com मली एसएमएस यानी कि
टेक्स्ट मैसेज और ईमेल का यूज किया जाता
है ईमेल ऑथेंटिकेशन या टेक्स्ट मैसेज के
थ्रू ऑथेंटिकेशन करने के लिए ठीक है बस तो
यहां पर जितने लोग है यार लाइक नहीं ठोका
आप लोगों ने यार लाइक काफी कम लोगों ने
ठोका है लाइक ठोकते जाओ अब यहां पर आते
हैं अब इसमें क्या गड़बड़ी होगी और इसकी
वजह से कौन सी वलने बिलिटी या कौन सी बग
जो है निकल के आती है तो बग क्या निकल के
आती है
सेशन नॉट एक्सपायरिंग
नॉट एक्सपायरिंग
इवन टर्निंग इवन टर्निंग ऑन एमएफए और
2f ये इसके अंदर आ जाता है अब इसका सिंपल
सा मतलब क्या हुआ सिंपल सा सिनेरियो आप
समझ लीजिए इसका बहुत सिंपल सा सिनेरियो है
मैं आपको यहां
पे समझा देता
हूं ठीक
है मैं यहां पे सिंपल सा एक सिनेरियो समझा
देता हूं
ठीक है यह सिंपल सा एक वाइट बोर्ड आ गया
मान लो यहां पर हमारे पास अब ना यहां पर
क्या है यहां पर मेरे पास एक अकाउंट है यह
और एक अकाउंट है यह यह दोनों अकाउंट कौन
से हैं यह दोनों मान लो यह अकाउंट ए है और
यह अकाउंट बी है अब आपने अकाउंट ए
पर अकाउंट ए पर लॉग इन कर लिया
आपने लॉग इन कर लिया अकाउंट बी पर लॉग इन
कर
लिया यह मैं माउस से कर रहा हूं तो थोड़ा
सा इग्नोर कीजिएगा राइटिंग को अब अकाउंट ए
को
आपने मान लो क्रम पर लॉग इन
किया क्रम प आपने लॉगइन किया अकाउंट और
आपने बी को जो है बी उसको आपने लॉग इन
किया किसी और ब्राउजर पर
फायरफॉक्स
आपने firefox.exe
सिक्योरिटी इंप्लीमेंटेशन कैसी होनी चाहिए
यूजुअली एक वेब एप्लीकेशन की सिक्योरिटी
इंप्लीमेंटेशन कैसी होनी चाहिए चैट में
मुझे बताइए कि कैसी होनी चाहिए कि जब आप
एक सेम अकाउंट को किसी और ब्राउजर पे जाके
वहां पे आप मल्टीफैक्टर ऑथेंटिकेशन इनेबल
कर रहे हैं तो जब आप दूसरे ब्राउजर जहां
आप लॉगिन है सेम अकाउंट से अगर आप उसको
रीलोड करते हैं या अगर आप उसमें कोई भी
ऑथेंटिकेशन का टास्क करते हैं या कोई भी
ऐसा टास्क उस पर्टिकुलर सेशन में कर रहे
हैं तो ऑटोमेटिक वो सेशन एक्सपायर हो जाना
चाहिए और ऑटोमेटिक आपका वो लॉग आउट हो
जाना चाहिए जनरल में जनरली जो है इस तरह
का होना चाहिए यही आपका जो सिक्योरिटी
इंप्लीकेशंस है वो होनी चाहिए जनरली किसी
भी तरह के अकाउंट में ठीक है ये सिंपल सा
फंड है अब यहां पे बात करते हैं इसको हम
एक प्रैक्टिकली समझते हैं कि इसको मैं
आपको थोड़ा सा लाइव दिखाता हूं कि ये किस
तरीके से काम करता है अब देखो जैसे मेरे
पास ना मान लो एक
इट्स यहां पर आपको दिख रहा होगा कि इट्स @
gmail.com ठीक है यह gmail.com
देन यहां पर पासवर्ड डालता
हूं ठीक है मैंने यहां पर पासवर्ड डाल
दिया यहां पर मैंने नेक्स्ट किया ठीक है
अब मैं नेक्स्ट करता हूं यहां पे नेक्स्ट
नॉट नाउ करता हूं यहां पे क्योंकि मुझे
पास की की जरूरत नहीं है और यह मेरा जो ग
अकाउंट है यह साइन इन हो चुका है मैं यहां
पर नॉट नाउ करके छोड़ देता हूं यहां प
साइन इन हो चुका है ठीक है मेरा यह जीमल
अकाउंट साइन इन हो गया आपको यहां पर दिख
रहा होगा सिंपल सा कि यहां प मैं टक्सन
सलूशन @ gmail.com यहां पर अवेलेबल है ठीक
है बहुत अच्छी अब मैं इसका मेल ओपन कर
लेता हूं भैया चलो मैं इसका
क्रम पे में टक्सन सोल्यूशन लगड इन है अब
मैं यहां पे ू एफ ऑन करता हूं मैं यहां पर
ू एफ टर्न ऑफ है मैं यहां प ू एफ को ऑन
करता हूं एफ पर क्लिक किया यहां पर
पासवर्ड मांग रहा है चलो ठीक है वह कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है 2 ए को इनेबल करने के लिए
यह पासवर्ड देना जरूरी है तो मैंने यहां
पे पासवर्ड
दिया टू स्टेप वेरिफिकेशन आप देख सकते हैं
टर्न ऑन का ऑप्शन आ रहा है यानी कि ऑफ है
ये टर्न ऑन मैं करता हूं टर्न ऑन करता हूं
यहां प नंबर मांगा जा रहा है तो मैं यहां
पर नंबर यहां पर इंडिया सिलेक्ट कर लेता
हूं आई एन नंबर देता
हूं चलिए मैंने यह नंबर दे दिया यह नंबर
मैंने दे दिया अब मैं इस नंबर पर ू ए ऑन
करता हूं मैं यहां पर नेक्स्ट पर क्लिक
करता
हूं यहां से कोड आएगा तो मैं कोड को एंटर
करूंगा वेटिंग फॉर द
कोड देखते हैं
ओके अभी तक कोड तो नहीं आया हां आ गया सो
इट्स
चलिए सो मैंने कोड डाल दिया है और यहां पे
टर्निंग ऑन टू स्टेप वेरिफिकेशन तो यहां
पे टू स्टेप वेरिफिकेशन ऑन हो चुका है
यहां पे आ रहा होगा यू आर नाउ प्रोटेक्टेड
विद द टू स्टेप वेरिफिकेशन मैं यहां पे डन
पे क्लिक कर देता हूं ठीक है टस्ट
वेरिफिकेशन यहां पे आप देख सकते हैं यहां
पे फोन नंबर ऑन हो गया एंड यहां पे टस्ट
टर्न ऑफ ऑप्शन आ रहा है और बैक
करेंगे तो यहां पे आ रहा है टस्ट
वेरिफिकेशन ऑन सिंस 752 पीएम अभी का अब
मैं दूसरे वाले प ब्राउजर पे चलता हूं एज
पे जहां पे मैंने इसको लॉगइन करके रखा है
इस वाले g मेल को सेम g मेल है आपका य आप
देखे यहां पे आप देखो मे सशन @ gmail.com
और 2f जो मैंने ऑन किया वो भी आपका सेम
यहां पे मे सशन @ gmail.com है ठीक है तो
अब मैं यहां पे एज पे चलता हूं और मैं
क्या करता हूं इसको रीलोड करता हूं आई एम
जस्ट गोइंग टू रीलोड दिस जीमल एंड यहां पर
रीलोड करके वेट करते हैं ठीक है यहां पर
यहां पर हमने रीलोड किया अब मैं यहां पर
एक कोई सा भी ऑथेंटिकेट काम करता हूं
मैनेज योर ग अकाउंट पर क्लिक करता हूं
लेट्स सी मैनेज योर ग अकाउंट प हम चले गए
अब यहां पे मैं सिक्योरिटी पर चलता हूं
आगे सिक्योरिटी पे एंड लेट्स डू वन
थिंग यहां
पे मान लो रिकवरी ईमेल है रिकवरी ईमेल प
चलते हैं यहां पे यहां पे रिकवरी ईमेल प
यहां पे बैक करते हैं यहां पे और और एक
बार अगेन यहां से रीलोड करते
हैं ओके टू वि स्टेप वेरिफिकेशन ऑन है
यहां पे अब यहां पे यूजुअली क्या अब देखो
यहां पे यूजुअली क्या होना चाहिए इस टू
स्टेप वेरिफिकेशन में क्या होना चाहिए
यहां पे हैप्पी टीचर्स डे सर आयशा गुप्ता
ओके हैप्पी टीचर्स डे यहां पे यूजुअली
क्या होना चाहिए यूजुअली क्या होना चाहिए
कि ये एक्सपायर्ड होना चाहिए यानी कि ये
जो सेशन है आपका एक्सपायर हो जाना चाहिए
जनरली ये एक
एक मिस कॉन्फिन है मल्टीफैक्टर ऑथेंटिकेशन
में अगर ऐसा नहीं होता है तो फिर क्या
होता है लेकिन अब इसमें क्या करेंगे हम
पासवर्ड चेंज करेंगे हम क्या करते हैं
अपने एज पे मैनेज अकाउंट प चलते
हैं एंड यहां चलते हैं सिक्योरिटी में
सिक्योरिटी में एंड यहां पे हम चलते हैं
पासवर्ड पे कहां गई पासवर्ड पासवर्ड यह
रहा लास्ट चेंज यहां पे आ रहा है पासवर्ड
पे चलते हैं पासवर्ड प चलने पे हम यहां पे
न्यू पासवर्ड यहां पे एंटर करते हैं न्यू
पासवर्ड कुछ भी न्यू पास पाड डाल देते
हैं मैंने न्यू पासवर्ड डाल दिया अब यहां
पर चलते
हैं मैंने न्यू पासवर्ड डाल दिया अब मैं
यहां पर चेंज पासवर्ड पर क्लिक करता हूं
यह बोल रहा है स्टे साइ स्टे साइंड यहां
पे रहेंगे ठीक है चेंज पासवर्ड प क्लिक
करते हैं एंड यहां पे पासवर्ड यहां पे
चेंज हो जा रहा है अब यहां पे पासवर्ड
मेरा दूसरे ब्राउजर पे मैंने सेम यहां पे
मैंने टू फैक्टर ऑथेंटिकेशन इनेबल कर रखा
है यहां पे मैंने टू फैक्टर ऑथेंटिकेशन
बाद इनेबल किया है सेम सेशन में यहां पे
आपका यह पासवर्ड जो है वो चेंज हो जा रहा
है सेम एज पे जाके ये चेंज हो जा रहा है
बट इस तरह की बिहेवियर यूजुअल किसी वेब
एप्लीकेशन का या किसी भी सिक्योर
एप्लीकेशन का नहीं होना चाहिए अगर ऐसा
होता है तो यह एक तरह का मिस कन्फेशन माना
जाता है अब बात यह है कि यहां पे
google2 चेंज करने दिया वहां पे मैंने 2
2f ऑन किया मल्टीफैक्टर ऑथेंटिकेशन ऑन
किया बट यहां पे भी मैं आराम से पासवर्ड
चेंज कर पा रहा हूं यहां पे ये जो चीज यह
मैं रीलोड कर पा रहा हूं तो ग का मानना है
ग का मानना है कि ग आपका जब आप किसी
अकाउंट में अपने डिवाइस को ना जब आपने
अकाउंट में आप किसी डिवाइस को रजिस्टर
करते हो रजिस्टर तो वह डिवाइस को रजिस्टर
करता है एंड उस डिवाइस को ट्रस्टेड मानता
है ग के केस में मैं आपको बता रहा हूं
क्या करता है उस डिवाइस को ग ट्रस्टेड
मानता है जैसे आप चलोगे यहां पे यहां पर
देखोगे यहां पर आप देखोगे ना
र डिवाइस ह यहां पे आप डिवाइसेज में
देखोगे यो डिवाइस में तो आप यहां पे देख
सकते हो कि
विंडोज यह सेशंस आप देखो आपको मैं दिखा
देता हूं यहां पे यह देखो अब यहां पे यह
वेरीफाई करने का आ रहा है अब यहां पे मैं
अगर यह
डिवाइसेज पे ये देखो यहां पे ये वन सेशन
ऑन विज कंप्यूटर ये डिवाइसेज आ रहा है ना
अब मैं इस पे क्लिक करता हूं यो डिवाइसेज
पे तो ये डिवाइसेज पे आ गए यहां पे ठीक है
ये सारी
डिवाइसेसपोर्ट डिवाइस के अंदर आता है आपका
यहां पे ठीक है यह किस में आता है
ट्रस्टेड डिवाइस के अंदर में अब ये
ट्रस्टेड डिवाइस में जो आपकी कम है वो
सॉरी जो आपका
वीडियो कभी-कभी रुक जा रही है ऐसा क्यों
हो रहा है
अ हेलो हेलो ऐसा तो नहीं होना चाहिए
बिकॉज नेटवर्क इज एब्सलूट
फाइन नेटवर्क गुड कनेक्शन
है ओके नेटवर्क इज एब्सलूट फाइन आई डोंट
नो क्या है उसको करेंगे उसको हम वो करते
हैं अ अरे हां हां और एक चीज हां बीच में
आपको बता देता हूं यहां पे हमने वीपीटी की
ट्रेनिंग लच की है गाइस मैं एक्चुअली
बताना भूल गया था वीपीटी ट्रेनिंग के बारे
में तो difference.com स्वीटी आप इस पर जा
सकते हैं यह मैं भूल गया था आपको बताना
ठीक है ये वीपीटी की ट्रेनिंग लच की है 14
सितंबर से इसकी क्लासेस स्टार्ट हो रही है
तो आप जो है इस ट्रेनिंग में आ सकते हैं
इसकी पूरी डिटेल्स आप इस पर आके ले सकते
हैं इसके ऊपर अनाउंसमेंट भी आ चुकी है आप
वीडियो भी देख सकते हैं
youtube2 10 सीट्स बचे हुए थे उसमें से अब
ज्यादा सीट्स नहीं है पांच सीट्स बचे हुए
हैं ओनली तो आपको आना है तो आप डिटेल देके
जरूर आप चेक आउट करके आ जाइएगा ठीक
है तो यहां पे
जीमल जो है आपकी उसको कंसीडर करता है एज अ
ट्रस्टेड डिवाइस ट्स वई यहां पे कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं अब देखो यहां पे मैं से ये
पासवर्ड मांग रहा है तो मैं यहां
पे पासवर्ड दे रहा हूं यहां पे जब हमने
पासवर्ड चेंज किया था तो यहां पे ये
डिटेक्ट हो रहा है और यहां पे अब जो है
यहां पे चीजें आ रही है कि भैया आपने जो
है वो साइन इन किया है अब आप प्रोमट पे
प्रोमट जो है उसको उस परे जाके एंड अलाउ
कीजिए ठीक है तो मैं यहां पर देख लेता हूं
यहां पे प्रोमट एक
बार अगर प्रोमट आता है
तो मेरे पास अभी तक कोई प्रोमट आया नहीं
है चलो कोई और वे यूज कर लेते
हैं नहीं मुझे लग रहा है उसी से करना
पड़ेगा
ओके चलिए प्रोमट ही ले लेते हैं टैप यस ऑन
फोन और
टैबलेट टैप यस ऑन फोन और पे टेबलेट ठीक है
तो मैं यहां पर आ लेता हूं मेरे पास शायद
प्रोमट आ जाएगी
अब हां जी तो मेरे पास एक प्रोमट आ गई अभी
जस्ट राइट नाउ तो मैं इसको यस कर देता हूं
ठीक है तो मैंने यहां पर यस कर दिया है अब
ये लॉगइन हो जाएगा ठीक है नाउ दिस विल बी
लगड इन लेट्स
सी हो जा यार जल्दी हो जा भाई कितनी बार
प्रोमट होगा अब
ओके फिर से मैं प्रम डालता हूं यहां पर
पटप यस न फोन और
टैबलेट ओके कोई प्रोमट की इशू आ रही है
मेरे ख्याल से आई थिंक मैंने पास जो चेंज
किया है तो यह शायद लॉग आउट हो चुका होगा
हा प्रोमट आ चुका है प्रोमट आ चुका है
हमारे पास तो मैं य पर यस कर देता
हूं ओके लेट्स प्रेस यस हो जा यार जल्दी
हो
जा ओके तो अब जाके
हुआ तो अब यहां पे ये जो चीज है ये लॉगइन
हो गई ठीक है यहां पे क्या हो गया ये अपना
लॉग इन हो गया तो ट्रस्टेड डिवाइस के कारण
बट यूज ये होना नहीं चाहिए अब जैसे मान लो
हम ये हैकर वन की एक रिपोर्ट पढ़ते हैं एक
हैकर वन पे हम एक रिपोर्ट पढ़ते हैं यहां
पे प्रीवियसली
क्रिएटेडटेड आफ्टर एमएफए एक्टिवेशन ठीक है
अब यहां पे देखते हैं यहां पे इन्होंने
दिया है ग्रामरली ने बोला है कि फाउंड अ
डिजाइन इशू इन एमएफए इंप्लीमेंटेशन वही
मिसकंफीग्रेशन बोलेंगे प्रीवियसली
क्रिएटेडॉक्युमेंट्सफ्रैगमेंट
अब देखो यहां पे इन्होंने क्या किया आ फ
आई फाउंड वन इशू रिलेटेड टू ए 2fs सिस्टम
कैसे किया है इन्होंने एक्सेस द सेम
अकाउंट ऑन . grammarly.com इन टू डिवाइसेज
ठीक है दो डिवाइसेज पे सेम अकाउंट को
एक्सेस करना है ऑन डिवाइस a गो टू अकाउंट
grammarly.com सिक्योरिटी कंप्लीट ऑल
स्टेप्स टू एक्टिवेट 2fs सिस्टम नाउ द 2fa
इज़ एक्टिवेटेड फॉर द अकाउंट नाउ बैक टू
डिवाइस b दूसरे डिवाइस पे दूसरे ब्राउज़र
पे जाइए
द द सेशन इज़ स्टिल एक्टिव तो आप दो
डिवाइसेज पे भी चेक कर सकते हैं कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं आप एक एक ही लैपटॉप के दो
ब्राउजर में ना चेक करके दो डिवाइसेज में
आप ये चेक कीजिएगा ज्यादा अच्छे से आपको
वहां पे रिजल्ट आपको समझ में आएगा ज्यादा
अच्छे से जो है वो आपको रिजल्ट मिलेगी ठीक
है बस सिंपल सा फंड है ज्यादा अच्छे से
रिजल्ट आपको मिलेगी तो यहां पे सेशन इज
स्टिल एक्टिव जैसे एक लैपटॉप मेरा अभी
जहां से मैं लाइव सेशन ले रहा हूं आपके और
दूसरा लैपटॉप जो होगा वो कोई और लैपटॉप जो
है कोई और जो जो डिवाइस है आप उस पर से
ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं जैसे मेरे पास एक
और एक और डिवाइस है ठीक है तो मैं एक और
डिवाइस मेरा ये लैपटॉप है मैं इसको एक बार
ओपन कर लेता हूं मेरा जो दूसरा लैपटॉप है
मैं उसको ओपन कर लेता हूं उसमें भी वो लगड
इन है तो मैं एक बार चेक कर लेता हूं ठीक
है लेट मी चेक
वंस तो मैंने यहां पे
किया ओके अब मैं यहां पेमल ओपन कर लेता
हूं एंड मैं यहां पे सेम मैक्सन वाली आईडी
ओपन करके देखता
हूं सेशन एक्सपायर्ड आ रहा है सो इट्स
कमिंग सेशन एक्सपायर्ड सो मैक्सन सोल्यूशन
का दूसरे डिवाइस प मेरा सेशन एक्सपायर्ड आ
रहा है मैं यहां प दिखा देता हूं मैं आपको
अपनी डिवाइस पे अ मैं सेम डिवाइस पे चेक
कर रहा था तो ट्रस्टेड सेशन में आ जा रहा
था वो तो आई होप यू कैन सी ऑल पता नहीं
मुझे दिख रहा है कि नहीं आपको वो इस तरीके
से कुछ दिख रहा होगा आपको शायद पता नहीं
आई डोंट नो बट एक बार देख लो एक बार दिख
रहा है सबको
गया हां एक लैपटॉप एक फोन भी चलेगा कोई
दिक्कत नहीं दिख रहा है क्या यहां पे ये
लॉग आउट हो गया है ये मेरा दूसरा मैकबुक
है तो मैं उसमें आपको दिखा रहा हूं ठीक है
आई डोंट नो दिखा है कि नहीं आपको बट थोड़ा
ट्रस्ट कर लो आज टीचर्स डे पे झूठ नहीं
बोलूंगा ठीक है ओके
तो यह जो है ना यह एक नॉर्मल सिनेरियो
होना
चाहिए
अह ठीक है हां डिलीट नहीं होगी टेंशन मत
लो यह नॉर्मल सिनेरियो में होना चाहिए कि
सेशन एक्सपायर हो जाना चाहिए जैसे ही एक
अकाउंट पे हमने 2f मान लो यार सिंपल सा
फंडा है ना आप खुद सोचो ना आप खुद सोचो
ऐसा ही होना चाहिए क्यों होना चाहिए मैं
आपको बताता हूं आप खुद सोचो कि मान लो
आपने अपना अकाउंट लॉगइन किया आपने सिस्टम
पे आप अपने फ्रेंड के पास गए आप फ्रेंड के
पास जाके लॉगइन करके चले आए अब उसमें यह
डू यू अग्री गाइस आप सब एग्री कर रहे इस
बात से ऐसा होना चाहिए ऐसा होना चाहिए कि
नहीं एक एक जेनुइन सिक्योरिटी प
इंप्लीमेंटेशन एक करेक्ट सिक्योरिटी
इंप्लीमेंटेशन ऐसा ही होना चाहिए कि नहीं
किसी भी अकाउंट प यह मुझे
बताइए कितने लोग एग्री करते हैं कितने लोग
डिसएग्री करते हैं
बताइए लेट मी नो एवरी
बडी पहले बताइए
अग्री अग्री कर
र ठीक
है समझ गए ठीक है तो यहां पर भी सेम है
यहां पर नाउ द टू एक्टिवेटेड फॉर दिस
अकाउंट बैक टू डिवाइस बी सॉरी रीलोड द पेज
द सेशन इ स्टिल एक्टिव मतलब यहां पर सेशन
स्टिल एक्टिव था इन्होंने
सीवीटी को मी कर दिया और ट्रैक कर दिया था
यह 2019 की बात है ठीक है यह 2019 की बात
है इनका वक जो है यह ट्रैग हुआ था और इनको
बाद में बाउंट भी मिली थी इस पर्टिकुलर
वने बिलिटी के लिए अब यहां पे एक और
रिपोर्ट प आते हैं यह रिपोर्ट है 2023 की
31 मार्च 2023 की इन्होंने जो रिसर्चर है
उन्होंने वर्डप्रेस में एक सबमिट किया था
रिपोर्ट ठीक है इन्होंने क्या था एक्सेस द
सेम अकाउंट ऑन एग्जांपल . कॉ इन टू डिवाइस
ऑन डिवाइस ए गो टू द example.com कंप्लीट
ऑल द स्टेप टू एफ इनेबल किया एंड अगेन फिड
बी पे जो डिवाइस सेशन है वह एक्टिव ही रह
गई है ठीक है यहां पर इन्होंने यह सारी
चीजें मेंशन करिए सब चीजें यहां पे दी है
यहां पे wordpress.org से ऑफिशियल
वर्डप्रेस प्लग इन पे आ चुका है यहां पे
यह सारी डिटेल्स वगैरह दे रही है काफी
ज्यादा उसके बाद यहां पे इनका ट्रैग हुआ
11 अप्रैल 2023 को ये ट्रैग हुआ यहां पे
एंड ट्रैग होके सब कुछ होते होते होते
होते फाइनली यहां पे होते होते होते सारी
चीजें यहां पे होते होते फाइनली फाइनली
फाइनली यहां पे एक्सेप्ट हो गए ट्राई हो
गया बट यह बाउंट के लिए एलिजिबल नहीं थी
बट स्टिल यह बग वैलिड एक्सेप्ट हुआ एंड
इसको एक्सेप्ट करके फिर आगे डिस्क्लोज भी
यहां पे किया गया है तो मतलब ये एक्सेप्ट
हुआ है ये वलने बिलिटी तो ये एक इसमें एक
रिपोर्ट थी दूसरा रिपोर्ट एक था शैडो देखो
ये बहुत शानदार रिपोर्ट है यहां पे सेशन
डज नॉट एक्सपायर आफ्टर टू एए इनेबल्ड ये
2023 की है नवंबर की लास्ट में 2023 की है
आप बोल सकते हैं साइड एफेस को रिपोर्ट
किया गया था यहां पे तो इन्होंने हैकर वन
के ट्रायक टीम ने इसको इनफॉर्मेटिव करके
क्लोज कर दिया था जी
हां हैकर वन के ट्रायक टीम ने इसको
इनफॉर्मेटिव क्लोज कर दिया था 1 नवंबर
2023 को उसके बाद इन रिसर्चर ने काफी
अच्छी खासी इनको सारी चीजें बताई सारी
चीजें डिस्क्लोज करी क्या-क्या चीजें हो
सकती है यहां पे इंटरनली फिर उसके बाद
यहां पर आप देख सकते हैं यहां पे यहां पर
डि कम बंद हुआ है उसके बाद यहां पे साइड
इफेक्टस के स्टाफ ने जो उनकी सिक्योरिटी
टीम होगी उन्होंने यहां पर बीच में इंटरवू
किया था एंड बोला था आफ्टर डिस्कसिंग
इंटरनली वी डिसाइडेड दैट योर सजेशन वाज
इंटरेस्टिंग दैट वी विल इंप्लीमेंट इट ऑन
आवर वेबसाइट उसके बाद मीडियम से लो कर
दिया था इसका सीवियरिंग एंड इसको ट्रैग कर
दिया था ट्रैग करने के बाद इसको बाउंट भी
दी थी यानी हैकर वन ने इसको इनफॉर्मेटिव
क्लोज की थी बट इस पर्टिकुलर प्रोग्राम के
सिक्योरिटी टीम ने इन्होंने इसको एक्सेप्ट
किया ट्रैक किया एंड इनको बाउंट भी
प्रोवाइड करी है तो इस तरह के जो
प्रोग्राम्स होते हैं ना ये काफी
इंटरेस्टिंग काफी अच्छे प्रोग्राम्स होते
हैं साइड इफेक्ट जैसे जो हैकर वन के
अगेंस्ट जाके अगेंस्ट नहीं बोलेंगे ऐसा
बोलेंगे कि उनसे उनका कोलाइड नहीं कर रहा
था उनकी चीजें अलाइन नहीं कर रही थी तो
उनके अलग उनसे अलग होक इन्होंने अपना एक
डिसीजन लिया एंड दे गिवन द बाउंट सो बाउंट
मिलती है रिवर्ड भी मिलता है आपका रिपोर्ट
तगड़ा होना चाहिए अब एक शानदार सबसे अच्छी
जो चीज है 2019 की जो है इसमें देखिए
बाउंट रिवर्ड
2500 की मिली
थी $500 अब देखो यहां पे क्या है
ईमेल एमएफए मोड अलाउ बाय पासिंग एमएफए
फ्रॉम विक्टिम्स डिवाइस वन द डिवाइस
ट्रस्ट इज नॉट एक्सपायर्ड यह बहुत शानदार
एक रिपोर्ट थी अब इस रिपोर्ट में क्या था
अब मैं आपको बताता हूं अब इस रिपोर्ट में
क्या था अ वलने बिलिटी वाज रिपोर्टेड इन
स्कोप इन स्कोप ऑफ द ग्रामरली एमएफए
चैलेंज ठीक है नो यूजर्स र अफेक्टेड यह
रिसर्चर है आईडेंटिफाइड वटी दैट अलाउड
बायपासिंग एमएफए इफ स्पेस कंडीशन वरमेट
क्या भाई था अटैकर हैज एक्सेस टू एचटीटीपी
ओनली सिक्योर टीडीआई कुकी ऑफ द विक्टिम
पर्टिकुलर डिवाइस अटैकर नोज यूजर एजेंट ऑफ
द विक्टिम डिवाइस अटैकर कैन इशू अ
क्राफ्टेड रिक्वेस्ट ड्यूरिंग अ फिक्स
टाइम फ्रेम आफ्टर द विक्टिम हैज साइंड इन
फ्रॉम अ पर्टिकुलर डिवाइस यू कैन डिस्कवर
एडिशनल डिटेल्स अबाउट दिस इन द कमेंट अब
देखो इन्होंने क्या किया था इट इज पॉसिबल
बायपास एमएफए विदाउट द नीड टू हैव द फोन
कोड मतलब फोन कोड की जरूरत नहीं है भाई
मतलब इसको फोन कोड की जरूरत नहीं है एमएफए
बायपास हो जाएगा मल्टी फैक्ट ऑथेंटिकेशन
ठीक है व्हेन वी टर्न ऑन द एमएफए एंड वी
हैव द यूजर एंड पासवर्ड ऑफ़ द यूजर इट इज
पॉसिबल टू बायपास द एमएफए ओनली चेंजिंग सम
वैल्यूज द एंड पॉइंट पोस्ट रिक्वेस्ट जो
एक पोस्ट रिक्वेस्ट है उसकी कुछ एंड
पॉइंट्स है कैसे यूज बॉब शूट और अनदर टूल
टू इंटरसेप्ट द रिक्वेस्ट टर्न ऑन एंड
कन्फर एमएफए एमएफए को पहले एक्टिवेट कर
लिया लॉग इन विथ योर ईमेल एंड पासवर्ड
लॉगइन कर लिया द पेज ऑफ एमएफए इज गोइंग टू
अपीयर ठीक है है एंटर एनी रैंडम नंबर अब
वहां पे एक कोड डालना होगा एमएफए का सिंपल
सा फंडा है ठीक है कोड डालना होगा ठीक है
बीच में अटक रहा है क्या किसी का वीडियो
ये बता दीजिए एक बार कुछ लोग बोल रहे हैं
बीच में अटक रहा है मुझे तो नहीं लग रहा
यार बीच में अटक रहा है शायद आपके साथ
नेटवर्क इशू होगा
पल्लव बीच में अटक रहा है क्या
कुछ बीच में कोई इशू आ रही है क्या वीडियो
में प्लीज लेट मी नो गा प्लीज सभी लोग बता
दीजिए एक बार ताकि क्लियर हो
जाए प्लीज सभी लोग बता दीजिए एक
बार कभी-कभी
नो ऐड नहीं आई आज ऐड नहीं आई है क्या आज
ऐड आ रही है यार आ रही है चलो मैं ड एक
इंसर्ट कर देता हूं एक ऐड ऐड की ऐड नहीं आ
रही थी तो ऐड डाल दिया मैंने चलो
ऑल गुड शायद नेटवर्क इशू होगा या कुछ होगा
चलिए देखिए यहां पे इंटर एनी रैंडम नंबर
अप टू एफ होगा मान लो या एमएफए होगा मान
लो कोड डालना ओटीपी डालना है तो नंबर
डालना कोई भी रैंडम नंबर डाल दीजिए व्हेन
यू प्रेस द बटन साइन इन सिक्योर इंटरसेप्ट
द पोस्ट रिक्वेस्ट साइन इन सिक्योर प जब
डालेंगे तो पोस्ट रिक्वेस्ट को इंटरसेप्ट
करेंगे उसके बाद थड gram.com
v3 एआई लॉगइन एंड इन द पोस्ट मैसेज चेंज द
फील्ड्स चेंज करना है
क्या मोड एसएमएस को मोड ईमेल कर दीजिए
यानी कि मोड को एसएमएस को हटा के ईमेल कर
देना है सिक्योर लॉगिन ट्रू को सिक्योर
लॉगिन को फाल्स कर दीजिए सिंपल से दो
फ्लैग्स थे इन्होंने एसएस मोड को ईमेल मोड
पे कर
दिया हां जी भाई आज तो वीडियो को लाइक कर
दो धन्यवाद धन्यवाद धन्यवाद भाई सपोर्ट
दिखाने के लिए और सिक्योर लॉगिन ट्रू को
फॉल्स कर दिया सेंड द मॉडिफिकेशन एंड चेक
यू आर इन अकाउंट इट वाज नॉट नेसेसरी टू
एंटर द फोन कोड यानी कि इन्होंने मल्टी
फैक्ट ऑथेंटिकेशन या टू फैक्ट ऑथेंटिकेशन
को बायपास किया एज सिंपल एट इन्होंने क्या
किया टू फैक्ट ऑथेंटिकेशन को बोले या
मल्टी फैक्टर ऑथेंटिकेशन को बोले इन्होंने
बायपास कर दिया सिंपल सा फंड है इससे ट्स
इट ठीक है तो यह चीज थी पूरी अब यहां पे
नीड्स मोर इंफो यहां पे आ र है नीड्स मोर
थैंक यू फॉर सबमिशन आई एम नॉट एबल टू सी
एनी एमफ सेटिंग्स अंडर माय अकाउंट सेटिंग
कैन यू प्लीज हेल्प मी टू फाइंड पाथ नेबल
ए फॉर एन अकाउंट यह देखो एफ सेटिंग नको
नहीं मिल रही है पता नहीं सॉरी फॉर द
कंफ्यूजन करेंटली रिपोर्ट टेड टू एमफ आर
ओनली ट्रैक्ड बाय
ग्रामरली ठीक है अब यहां पे आ रहा है वी
कैन नॉट रिपस द इशू यू हैव रिपोर्टेड
प्लीज प्रोवाइड अ डिटेल पीसी द एसटीटीपी
रिक्वेस्ट विच अलाउ बायपासिंग इन्होंने
किया है उसके बाद यहां प कुछ चेंजेज आए
हैं उसके बाद यहां पे ट्राय आया है व और
क्रिटिकल से मीडियम इसको डाला गया है एंड
यहां पे थैंक्स फॉर रिपोर्ट वी कंफर्म दिस
रिपोर्ट एज वैलिड सॉरी फॉर द लेट रिस्पांस
आई एम ग्लैड यू प्रोड्यूस लेट मी नो डू
समथिंग यहां कुछ नहीं यहां पर इनको $500
की बाउंट मिल गई है
ठीक है और यहां पे कुछ इनसाइट है इसको आप
जरूर पढ़िए इस रिपोर्ट को आप जरूर पढ़िए
आपको काफी ज्यादा नॉलेज मिल जाएगी इस
पर्टिकुलर वनबिल के रिगार्डिंग काफी
ज्यादा आपका जो माइंड है ना वो ओपन हो
जाएगा कि भैया इस तरीके की चीजें भी हो
सकती है इस तरीके की चीज ठीक है हैकर वन
पे प्राइवेट प्रोग्राम या बक राउड पे प्रा
प्राइवेट इनवाइट चाहिए तो आप उस पे रेगुलर
रहिए बक राउड पे रेगुलर हंट करते रहिए
हैकन पे रेगुलर हंट करते रहिए प्राइवेट
प्रोग्राम्स ऑटोमेटिक आना शुरू हो जाएंगे
बस नॉट एप्लीकेबल वाली चीजें मत कीजिएगा
इंफॉर्मेशन में भी क्लोज हो रही है आपका
अगर अगर आपने बग्स फाइंड किए ब फाइ कर रहे
इनफॉर्मेटिव क्लोज हो रही है देन आपके तब
भी आप जो है चांसेस है आपके कुछ वैलिड
बक्स भी मिल जाए प2 पी3 वगैरह निकाल लीजिए
या पव निकाल लीजिए इस तरीके के तो भी आपके
चांसेस बन जाएंगे ठीक है तो कहने का मतलब
है कुछ इस तरीके से यह चीजें काम कर रही
है ठीक है आप समझ समझ में आपको आ गया होगा
अब मैं क्या काम करता हूं मैं क्या काम
करता
हूं कोई एक लाइफ टारगेट
प एक टारगेट पर चलते हैं एंड ये टारगेट है
ओ डॉट इंडस्ट्रीज य एप्लीकेशन है ओन ड
इस्ट्री एक यूआरएल है मैं इस पर चलता हूं
और मेरे दूसरे वाले लैपटॉप पे भी मैं इस
सेम यूआरएल को ओपन कर लेता हूं इस सेम जो
हमारा डोमेन है इसको ओपन कर लेता हूं तो
लेट मी ओपन
इट ओसेंट
इंडस्ट्री मेरे दूसरे लैपटॉप में ये लॉगिन
नहीं है शायद मैं देख लेता हूं एक बार
ओसेंट इंडस्ट्रीज ये
रहा मैं यहां पे इसको लॉग इन कर लेता हूं
सेम अकाउंट से मैं लॉग इन कर रहा हूं साइन
अप यहां पे लॉगइन का पेज आएगा शायद मेरे
ख्याल से लेट मी सी हां जी तो यहां
पर साइन इन का ऑप्शन आ चुका है मैं यहां
पर साइन इन कर रहा हूं सो लेट मी साइन इन
फर्स्ट तो मुझे साइन इन करना है सो एवरी
बडी प्लीज अलाउ मी टू साइन
इन सो
प्लीज अलाउ मी गाइस जस्ट टू साइन इन लिटिल
बिट चलिए थोड़ी देर थोड़ा देर थोड़ी देर
वेट कीजिए मैं य पर ईमेल डाल लेता हूं
अ
jio.in यहां मैंने साइन इन कर दिया लेट मी
सी इफ गेट गेट साइन इन हां जी तो यहां पे
यह साइन इन हो चुका है ठीक है तो इसमें भी
मैंने साइन इन कर लिया है सेम अकाउंट को
अब मैं क्या कर देता हूं ना अब मैं आपको
दिखाता हूं यहां पे यह अकाउंट जो है इस पे
चलते हैं इस अकाउंट के सेटिंग्स में चलते
हैं यहां पे सेटिंग्स
में ठीक है सेटिंग्स में आ गए हम यहां पे
और यहां पे हम ू एए ऑथेंटिकेटर पप टू
फैक्टर ऑथेंटिकेशन इनेबल करते हैं हम यहां
पे क्या कर देते हैं टू फैक्टर ऑथेंटिकेशन
जो है इनेबल करते हैं अब इस टू फैक्टर
ऑथेंटिकेशन को इनेबल करने के लिए मेरे को
googlethalli.com कोड के स्कैन किया मैंने
एंड यहां पे यह चीज आ चुकी है यहां पर
क्या हो गया मेरा googlethalli.com
ठीक है मैं य पर ईमेल आईडी डाल देता
हूं तो मैं यहां
पर ईमेल आईडी डाल रहा हूं एंड यहां पर मैं
यहां पर साइन इन कर रहा हूं ठीक है आईम
जस्ट साइनिंग
इन साइन कर रहा यहां पर तो य पर साइन इन
हो चुका य पर मैं य अकाउंट पर चलता हूं
सेटिंग्स पर चलता हूं यहां
पर एंड यहां
पर ऑथेंटिकेटर प वाली जो है यहां पर अच्छा
अच्छा यहां पर वेरिफिकेशन ऑन करना पड़ेगा
यहां पर वेरिफिकेशन यहां पर डालना पड़ेगा
तो मैं य पर वेरिफिकेशन डाल के इसको पहले
इनेबल कर लेता हूं
तो तो मैंने य पर डाला एंड य पर सेव कर
दिया ठीक है सेव कर दिया ट्स इट यहां पर आ
रहा है इनवैलिड आ रहा है अरे ऐसे कैसे आ
रहा है यार इनवैलिड कैसे आ रहा है चलो मैं
दूसरा डाल देता हूं यहां
पर यहां पर मैं डाल रहा हूं यहां
पर इनवैलिड आ रही है य आई डोंट नो इनवैलिड
क्यों आ रहा है
यह ओके एक काम कर देते हैं
[संगीत]
लेट्स डू वन
थिंग मैं अगेन यहां पर फिर से एक बार करता
हूं ठीक है तो
6 यहां पर करता हूं मैं इसको सेव करते हैं
देखते हैं इस बार इस बार इनवैलिड तो नहीं
होना चाहिए हां जी तो यह हो गया तो य प
आरहा चेंजेज हैज बीन सेव्ड एंड यहां पे अब
ये हो चुका है अब ये देखो यहां पे 2f है
यहां पे कोड जनरेट हो चुकी है नहीं नहीं
नहीं नहीं भाई नहीं नहीं नहीं कुछ नहीं
हुआ कि कोई और लॉगइन कैसे कर लेगा खुद
सोचो यार दिमाग लगाओ थोड़ा यार थोड़ा
दिमाग लगाओ कोई और कैसे करेगा थोड़ा सा तो
थोड़ा सा दिमाग लगाओ ठीक है यहां पे पहले
वही अगर कोई और स्कैन कर भी लेता है ये
पर्टिकुलर क्यूआर कोड मान लो लेट्स सपोज
किसी ने स्कैन कर भी लिया तो यहां पे जो
कोड मैं डालूंगा ना वो जो वेरीफाई करने के
लिए वो मेरे ही कोड से डा रही है ना यार
उसकी कोड में कैसे जान जाऊंगा और उसका कोड
मैं कैसे ऐड कर लूंगा है ना दिमाग थोड़ा
तो लगाया करो
यार ठीक है तुम साइबर सिक्योरिटी के
स्टूडेंट हो यार इतना लगाना
पड़ेगा है ना इतना दिमाग लगाना पड़ेगा चलो
तो यहां पर अब टू फैक्ट इनेबल हो चुकी है
अब मैं यहां पर क्या करता हूं मेरे दूसरे
वाले अकाउंट में मैं इसको क्या करता हूं
एक बार रीलोड करता हूं लेट्स रिड इट लेट्स
सी व्ट इज
हैपनिंग एंड यह स्टिल लगड इन है आई थिंक
स्टिल इट्स लगड इन लेट मी सी हां जी यह
देखिए दूसरा वाला जो अकाउंट है यह यहां पर
मैं आपको दिखा रहा हूं आई डोंट नो कितना
दिखेगा क्या दिखेगा बट स्टिल लेट मी शो यू
यहां पर यह दूसरा अकाउंट है दूसरे डिवाइस
में देखिए एक बार यह स्टिल लगड इन है मैं
इसको रीलोड लो जो भी है कर पा रहा हूं सब
कुछ कर पा रहा हूं थोड़ा भरोसा रखिए इस
चीज को इस चीज प तो यह जो है सेशन जो है
इसका सेशन तो इसका एक्सपायर नहीं हुआ यहां
पे मैं स्टिल यहां पे रीलोड कर पे रहा हूं
और अब यहां पे है चेंज पासवर्ड जो चेंज
पासवर्ड भी करके देखेंगे तो चेंज पासवर्ड
भी अगर आपका हो जाता है तो इट्स स्टिल
अवेलेबिलिटी तो मोस्ट ऑफ द केसेस में आपको
क्या देखना है कि चेंज पासवर्ड करके आपको
देखना है ठीक है तो इतना तो पता चल गया
भैया कि ये जो है स्टिल क्या है अभी भी
आपका लॉगइन है दूसरी जगह पे वहां पे लॉग
आउट हो जाना चाहिए था जब मैं दूसरी
फंक्शनैलिटीज पे जा रहा हूं वहां पे लॉग
आउट हो जाना चाहिए था एंड
दैट्ची चीज नहीं ये लेबिलिटी यानी कि यहां
एजिस्ट कर है अब इनका कोई बग बाउंट
प्रोग्राम नहीं है वो अलग वो अलग बात है
बट स्टिल लेबिलिटी एजिस्ट करती है तो कहने
का सिंपल सा मतलब है कि एक अकाउंट को दो
डिवाइसेज एक मेंटू एए या एमएफए ल इनेबल
कीजिए दूसरे पे चेक कीजिए उसका पासवर्ड
चेंज करके सबसे ज्यादा बढ़िया है कि दूसरे
पे पासवर्ड चेंज करके उसका देखिए अगर
पासवर्ड चेंज हो जा रहा है ना इट मींस ये
तो पक्का से वल्नरेबल है 110 पर वल्नरेबल
है और उसको आप रिपोर्ट कर सकते हैं
क्योंकि जब आपने एक जगह एमएफए ऑन कर दिया
है और दूसरे अकाउंट में दूसरे डिवाइस
पासवर्ड चेंज हो जा रहा है इसका मतलब है
वो एमएफए कन्फर ही नहीं हुआ है सही से व
सही से कन्फर हुआ ही नहीं है एंड दैट इज अ
डिजाइन इशू दैट इज अ डिजाइन इंप्लीमेंटेशन
इशू सिक्योरिटी इंप्लीमेंटेशन इशू ऑफ
मल्टी फैक्टर ऑथेंटिकेशन या टू फैक्टर
ऑथेंटिकेशन एंड दैट शुड बी रिपोर्टेड बाय
यू एस अ वलने बिलिटी ठीक है समझ में
आया बताइए जल्दी बताइए समझ में आया आप
सबको सबको समझ में आ रहा
है य चीज है यस इट्स लो हैंगिंग फ्रूट
एब्सलूट करेक्ट इट्स लो हैंगिंग फ्रूट इटस
कम मतलब इट इ अंडर लो हैंगिंग फ्रूट आप लो
हैंगिंग फ्रूट ही इसको मान सकते हैं जी हा
बिल्कुल यह लो हैंगिंग फ्रूट ही है
आपका ठीक है एवरीवन गट
इट एन गट इट
ठीक है चलिए अच्छी बात है अच्छी बात
है देखो सीविरियस
नॉट एक्सपायरिंग इवेंट सेशन नॉट
एक्सपायरिंग इवन
आफ्टर टर्निंग ऑन एमएफ
और
और बस यही सिंपल सा सेशन एक्सपायर नहीं हो
रहा पासवर्ड कैन बी
चेंज ऑन अदर
डिवाइस ऑफ
सेम सेम लगड इन अकाउंट इवन आफ्टर इनेबलिंग
एम एफ ए और ट एफ ए
एफ ऑन द अकाउंट ऑन वन
डिवाइस ठीक है तो यह जो है ना ये सिंपल सा
फंडा है इसकी सीवियरिंग आपका इसकी
सीवियरिंग आपकी लो भी हो सकती है इसकी
सीवियरिंग मीडियम भी हो सकती है और इसकी
सीवियरिंग हाई भी हो सकती है मैं लिटरली
बता रहा हूं और ये किस पे डिपेंड करता है
पता है ये मुझे बताइए आपको बताना है कि
इसकी सीवियरिंग क्या होगी यह किस पे
डिपेंड करता है बताइए
मुझे बताइए मुझे मैं चैट देख रहा
हूं करेक्ट एब्सलूट करेक्ट वैसे तो जितनी
विनेबिलिटी आप रिपोर्ट करते हैं सबकी
सीवियरिंग एक तरह से क्वालिटी ऑफ रिपोर्ट
पर डिपेंड करती है बट इसकी जो है टोटली
रिपोर्ट के ऊपर डिपेंड करती है कि आप
कितना इंपैक्टफुल दिखा पा रहे हैं आप अगर
कोई एमएफए का डिजाइन इंप्लीकेशन इशू है
डिजाइन इंप्लीमेंटेशन इशू है सिक्योरिटी
इंप्लीमेंटेशन इशू है तो उसका कितना
इफेक्टिव है वो आप दिखाना है वो आपको
दिखाना है दैट्ची
चलिए अच्छा
है चलिए बढ़िया है यहां
पर ओके ओके
ओके देखो मतलब एक बात मैं बताता हूं आपको
यार जब हम वो वाली चीज कर रहे थे ट्रीट
वाली जब मैं कर रहा था तब तो यार कितने
लोग थे पता है ना 150 से ज्यादा लोग आ गए
थे ट्रीट वाली पे अभी देखो 100 आ गए सब
ट्रीट खाने में बिजी हो गए हैं आजर सब आज
तो 200 लाइक हो गया भाई 200 लाइक हो गया
आज क्या बात
है चलिए नहीं अभी तो कोई भी ट्रीट वाली
काम मैं नहीं कर रहा हूं उसका जो टाइम था
वो टाइम था अब मैं नहीं करूंगा
एक्सट्रीमली सॉरी जब कर जब कर रहा था तभी
कर रहा था तो टोटली आपके क्वालिटी ऑफ
रिपोर्ट पे डिपेंड करता है अब इन्होंने एक
ये वाली जो रिपोर्ट है जिसमें $500 की
बाउंट लगी है इनका जो रिपोर्ट है वो बहुत
ही शानदार रिपोर्ट है इन्होंने इसमें
इन्होंने इसमें ना अलग तरीके का एक बाईपास
किया आप ऐसा भी कर सकते हो ऐसा भी ट्राई
आउट कर सकते हो कि मान लो आप देखो मान लो
कि किसी पर्टिकुलर
वेबसाइट में आपने क्या किया 2 एए देखा टू
फैक्ट ओटीपी देखा अब आप ओटीपी वाली जो
रिक्वेस्ट है उसको इंटरसेप्ट कर रहे हो
बॉब शूट से इंटरसेप्ट करने के बाद बॉब शूट
में आप आ रहे हो और वहां पे उन रिक्वेस्ट
के साथ खेल रहे हो जैसे इन्होंने क्या
किया इन्होंने उसी पर्टिकुलर रिक्वेस्ट को
एक्सेप्ट किया इंटरसेप्ट किया और मोड जो
ओटीपी मोड था एसएमएस से ईमेल कर दिया
सिक्योर लॉगइन को ट्रू से फॉल्स कर दिया
दैट्ची जो है इस तरीके की जो चीजें आप भी
ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं मल्टीफैक्टर ऑथ
केशन वाली लेबिलिटी में सेशन नॉट
एक्सपायरिंग इवन आफ्टर इनेबलिंग
मल्टीफैक्टर ऑथेंटिकेशन और टू फैक्टर
ऑथेंटिकेशन या यू कैन चेंज इवन पासवर्ड इन
दैट पर्टिकुलर सेशन अगर आप यह कर लेते हैं
तो आपको 100% वो जो पर्टिकुलर बग है वो एक
वैलिड बग माना जाएगा नॉट एप्लीकेबल तो कभी
नहीं होगा याद रखिएगा तो वैलिड बग उसको
माना
जाएगा ठीक
है समझ में आ गया एवरी बडी यह बहुत ही
सिंपल सा एक लो हैंगिंग फ्रूट ही था एक
बहुत ही सिंपल सा लेबिलिटी
था ठीक है क्या
य कोई बात नहीं विनय कोई बात
नहीं क्या क्या
है ज्ञान सिंह स्टार्टिंग से लेक्चर देखूं
या लाइव जवाइन करूं लाइव भी देख सकते हो
और स्टार्टिंग से अपना कंटिन्यू
करो हां सारे ट्रीट लेकर भाग गए सही बोला
सारे ट्रीट लेकर भाग गए मैं बढ़िया
एव ठीक है यह समझ में आ गया नहीं देखो ू
एफ बायपास जो होती है ना वो कुछ नहीं होती
है ू एफ बायपास भी जो है ना वो एक डिजाइन
इशू भी डिजाइन इशू है अब यह है ना यह है
सिक्योरिटी डिजाइन इशू ठीक है या
सिक्योरिटी इंप्लीमेंटेशन
इशू या इसको बोलो
एमएफए या 2
एए मिस
कॉन्फिन ठीक है मिस कॉन्फिन वगैरह हो रही
है मिस कन्फेशन हुई है तो यह लेबिलिटी जो
है व निकल के आती है तो इस तरीके की आपको
लेबिलिटी जो है वो आपको फाइंड आउट करनी है
अलग-अलग अलग-अलग जो वेबसाइट्स है उन सब पे
बकड वगैरह पे भी काफी सारे जो हैं वो बक
राउड पे काफी सारे जो है वो ऐसे
प्रोग्राम्स आपको मिलेंगे जो प्रोग्राम्स
जो है वो मल्टी फैक्टर या टू फैक्टर
ऑथेंटिकेशन को सपोर्ट करती है वहां जाइएगा
आप सिंपल सा आपको क्या करना है मैं आपको
पूरा प्रोसेस बता देता हूं ठीक
है सिंपल प्रोसेस टू फाइंड दिस वलन बिलिटी
पहला फाइंड ऑ
प्रोग्राम च
इज
हैविंग फीचर टू इनेबल एमएफ और ू
एफ ठीक
है मेक एन
अकाउंट और लॉग इन ओबवियसली आपको पता होगा
तो लॉगिन और अकाउंट तो बन जाएगा लॉग इन कर
लेना
है तीसरे में क्या
है लॉग इन विथ सेम अकाउंट ऑन अनदर
डिवाइस चार
में ठीक है एट डिवाइस वन ए डिवाइस वन
अलिर डिवाइस एट डिवाइस वन आपको क्या करना
है इनेबल द एमएफ
और ू एफ
ऑथेंटिकेशन ठीक है आपको इनेबल कर देना
है पांच में पाच फिथ पॉइंट क्या
है गो टू सेकंड
डिवाइस एंड रीलोड द पेज और डू एनी
सेशन
एक्टिविटी और ट्राई टू चेंज पासवर्ड ऑन
दिस
अकाउंट इफ ट गट
सक्सेसफुल द वेब द
एप्लीकेशन इज वल्नरेबल
और इफ इट स्टार्ट आस्किंग फॉर पास पासवर्ड
और एमएफए और सेशन गॉट
एक्सपायर गट एक्सपायर देन इट्स नॉट
वल्नरेबल बस सिंपल सा फंड है बस यही स्टेप
है ठीक है ये सिंपल सा छोटा सा स्टेप है
बहुत बड़ा स्टेप नहीं है कि प्रोग्राम
आपको फाइंड करना है उसमें एक फीचर इनेबल
जिसमें कि एमएफए 2 एए वाला फीचर हो लॉगिन
आपको कर लेना है एक डिवाइस पे और उसके बाद
आपको क्या करना है एक डिवाइस पे लॉगइन
दूसरे डिवाइस पे भी लॉग इन कर लेना है सेम
अकाउंट को अब एक पहले वाली डिवाइस पे आना
है और वहां पे आके 2f ए एमएफए को इनेबल कर
देना है दूसरे वाले डिवाइस पे जाना है
वहां पे रीलोड करना है पेज को अगर रीलोड
हो जा रहा है वर्किंग हो रही है नॉर्मली
बिना लॉग आउट हुए सेशन एक्सपायर हुए या
पासवर्ड चेंज कर पा रहे हैं तो दैट इट
मींस इट इज वल्नरेबल यू शुड रिपोर्ट दैट
ठीक है बस आप रिपोर्ट कर दीजिएगा कोई बात
नहीं ओके ग्रेट ग्रेट ग्रेट बिट टू
टेराबाइट चलिए चलिए हो गया दैट्ची अ आप
सबको यह वनबिल समझ में आ गई आप सब इस
वनबिल पे अभी हंट करना शुरू कर दीजिएगा
अभी से लेके नेक्स्ट क्लास तक जो जो लाइव
में मतलब जो जो अभी इस साथ में मेरे चल
रहे हैं तो अभी से लेकर नेक्स्ट क्लास तक
आप एमएफए वाली जो लेबिलिटी है यानी कि
सेशन नॉट एक्सपायरिंग इवन आफ्टर इनेबलिंग
मल्टीफैक्टर ऑथेंटिकेशन और टू फैक्टर
ऑथेंटिकेशन इस पे हंट करना शुरू कर
दीजिएगा कुछ ना कुछ आपको अच्छा मिल जाएगा
मैं आपको गारंटी दे रहा हूं अगर आपने सही
से हंट किया और अच्छा रिपोर्ट बया अच्छा
रिपोर्ट तैयार कीजिएगा अगर आपने अच्छा
रिपोर्ट तैयार किया तभी आपको कुछ मिलेगा
या तभी कुछ हो पाएगा अच्छा रिपोर्ट तैयार
नहीं किया तो दिक्कत होगी तो फिर वो
इनफॉर्मेटिव में मोस्टली क्लोज हो जाएगी
बट अच्छा रिपोर्ट तैयार करेंगे तो वो
एक्सेप्ट भी हो जाएगी वैलिड के तौर पे और
हो सकता है आपको बाउंट या रिवॉर्ड या
स्वैग कुछ भी मिल जाए या हॉल ऑफ फेर मिल
जाए ठीक है तो इस पे हंट कीजिएगा सिंपल सा
फंड है बहुत सिंपल सा स्टेप था इसलिए
मैंने इस पे ज्यादा टाइम नहीं लिया
क्योंकि ज्यादा टाइम लेने का कोई फायदा
नहीं है ठीक है ज्यादा टाइम लेने का कोई
मतलब नहीं है जब वनबिल या बग जब छोटा
एक्सप्लेनेशन हो उसका तो छोटा ही करना है
उसको बिना मतलब का एक्सपेंड करना बहुत
बेकार चीज है ठीक है तो ये मैंने छोटा ही
रखा है कि बस सिंपल सा फंडा वैसे
प्रोग्राम्स ढूंढिए जिसमें टू फैक्टर
एमएफए का है अ सेटिंग्स इनेबल करने का सेम
अकाउंट को आप एक डिवाइस पे लॉगिन कीजिए
दूसरे डिवाइस पे सेम अकाउंट को और पहले पे
आके इनेबल कीजिए एमएफए दूसरे पे जाके
देखिए कि वो वहां से लॉगआउट आपका सेशन
एक्सपायर हो रहा है कि नहीं हो रहा है
नहीं हो रहा है ट्स इट वल्नरेबल है
पासवर्ड चेंज करके दिखाइए और भी चीजें
जैसा कि मैंने इस रिपोर्ट के अकॉर्डिंग
बताया आपको हैकर वन के रिपोर्ट के
अकॉर्डिंग आप इसको बायपास करने का भी
थोड़ा बहुत दिमाग लगा सकते हैं कि भैया
एमएफए है मल्टीफैक्टर ऑथेंटिकेशन या 2 एए
है तो वो वो काम ही ना कर रहा हो ऐसा कि
मैं उसको बायपास ही कर दूं ऐसे कुछ-कुछ
छेड़छाड़ छेड़छाड़ या वैसे करके इसके ऊपर
मैं अलग से एक क्लास लूंगा टेंशन नहीं
लेना है आपको टू फैक्टर ऑथेंटिकेशन या
एमएफए ऑथेंटिकेशन बायपास का जो अप्रोच
होता है तरीका इस पे अगर आपको क्लास चाहिए
तो बताइए वो मैं अलग से लूंगा उसमें मैं
आपको सिर्फ बायपास टेक्निक्स किस तरीके से
काम करती है ना लाइक एमएफए बायपास टूएफ ए
बायपास टेक्निक्स को कैसे आप अप्रोच कर
सकते हैं अलग-अलग वेबसाइट्स पे अलग-अलग
वेब एप्लीकेशन पे वो मैं आपको उस सेशन में
बताऊंगा उस क्लास में बताऊंगा तो अगर आपको
ऐसी कोई क्लास चाहिए तो मुझे बताइए एंड आई
विल ब्रिंग इट ठीक है तो उसमें थोड़ा
डिटेल में बायपास प बात करेंगे ये तो
नॉर्मल सा हो गया की सेशन एक्सपेंड नहीं
हो रहा ये एक लेबिलिटी लेकिन वो एक बायपास
टी अगर वो आपने कर लिया तो वो तो 100%
सिर्फ बाउंट ही लगेगी वो थोड़ा सीवियर
सीवियर कैटेगरी में आ जाता है तो मुझे बता
दीजिए अगर आपको चाहिए तो
एवरीवन एवरीवन
प्लीज बहुत कम लोग रिप्लाई कर रहे हैं यार
काफी कम लोग ने रिप्लाई किया
बायपास वाली चाहिए ज्यादा लोग रिप्लाई
करोगे तभी कुछ होगा यार सभी लोग रिप्लाई
कर लो सभी लोग सभी लोग रिप्लाई मार दो
फटाफट रिप्लाई मार
दो चाहिए ठीक है मैं लेकर आ जाऊंगा और हां
मैं लेकर आ जाऊंगा अगेन मैं एक लास्ट टाइम
बोल देता हूं यहां पे कि fix.com स्वीटी प
आइएगा ये हमारा वीपीटी का एक ट्रेनिंग
सिक्स मंथ्स का एक वीकेंड ऑनलाइन लाइव
ट्रेनिंग कम इंटर्नशिप कम सर्टिफिकेशन कम
मॉक इंटरव्यूज कम जॉब ओरिएंटेड जॉब
प्लेसमेंट ओरिएंटेड एंड जॉब फोकस ट्रेनिंग
प्रोग्राम पहली बार हम लॉन्च कर रहे हैं
जिसका डीसीपीटी डीसीपीटी नाम है यहां पे
एंड यहां पे आप इस पे आके सारी डिटेल्स
चेक आउट कर लीजिएगा इसमें ऑलरेडी सीट्स
फुल हो चुके थे हमने सीट्स फिर से
एक्सटेंड किए वो भी फुल हो गए 10 सीट हमने
इंक्रीज किए पांच उसमें से बस बचे हुए हैं
एंड ये आपके ऊपर है आप आइए इस ट्रेनिंग
में आपके काफी ज्यादा आपके लिए बहुत
इंटरेस्टिंग होने वाला है इस ट्रेनिंग को
बेसिकली स्टूडेंट्स जो होंगे जो फ्रीलांस
करना चाहते हैं वीपीटी के प्रक्स उठाना
चाहते हैं वीपीटी के प्रोजेक्ट पे काम
करना चाहते हैं वो भी ट्रेनिंग में आ सकते
हैं कॉलेज स्टूडेंट्स फर्स्ट सेकंड ईयर
जॉब तो नहीं लगेगी बट अगर आप फ्रीलांस की
तरह काम करना चाहते हैं वीपीटी के
प्रोजेक्ट उठाना चाहते हैं तो आप आ सकते
हैं कॉलेज स्टूडेंट्स थर्ड एंड फाइनल ईयर
आपके लिए गोल्डन अपॉर्चुनिटी है इंटर्नशिप
के साथ-साथ सिक्स मंथ्स का इंडस्ट्रियल
मतलब ट्रेनिंग और इंडस्ट्रियल इंटर्नशिप
आपको मिल रही है प्राइवेट प्रोग्राम्स पे
और बहुत कुछ चीजें हम करने वाले हैं तो
आपके लिए गोल्डन अपॉर्चुनिटी है एंड
प्लेसमेंट असिस्टेंट आपको मिलेगी लाइक मॉक
इंटरव्यूज कैसे इंटरव्यू देना ना है कैसे
इंटरव्यू के लिए प्रिपेयर करना है कैसे
क्या करना है क्योंकि इसके ट्रेनर जो है
वो थ्री प्लस ईयर्स काफ एक्सपीरियंस है
उनको एंड अभी मल्टीनेशनल कंपनी में सीनियर
सिक्योरिटी कंसल्टेंट की तरह काम कर रहे
हैं तो आपके लिए बहुत ही शानदार खतरनाक एक
अपॉर्चुनिटी है ये ठीक है बग हंटर्स जो बग
बाउंट सीरीज को फॉलो कर रहे हैं उनके लिए
तो बहुत ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है आ जाइएगा
वीपीटी का एक अलग सिनेरियो आपको इंडस्ट्री
में कैसे काम होता है प्रोजेक्ट पे कैसे
सिक्योरिटी प्रोजेक्ट पे काम किए जाते हैं
सिक्योरिटी रिसर्चस के द्वारा एनालिस्ट के
द्वारा आपको सब कुछ पता चलेगा ठीक है ये
प्लेस स्टूडेंट्स वगैरह हैं किसी भी पार्ट
पे यहां पे मॉड्यूल सुपर में दिए हैं आप
मॉड्यूस को डाउनलोड करके इसको देख सकते
हैं डाउनलोड मॉड्यूस पे क्लिक कीजिएगा
सारे मॉड्यूल जो है आपको इस ट्रेनिंग के
यहां पे आपको मिल जाते हैं कि मॉड्यूस में
क्या-क्या चीजें हैं किस तरीके से हैं
सारी मिल जाएंगी आपको ठीक है क् बटन पे
क्लिक करके आप यहां से सिंपल आके इनरोल कर
सकते हैं सिंपल वन टाइम पेमेंट आपको थ्री
इंस्टॉलमेंट्स में 15000 फी है 5000 5000
अभी 5000 रिमेनिंग टू मंथ टू मंथली
इंस्टॉलमेंट और अगर आप वन टाइम करते हैं
इसको टिक कर दीजिएगा तो 1000 का एडिशनल
डिस्काउंट
दैट्ची चीज है ठीक है तो आप इस पे आके इस
पे ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं इफ यू आर हां
कौन एलिजिबल है तो मैंने आपको ऑलरेडी बोला
कि जो आप अगर इनरोल कर रहे हैं और आप अगर
हमारी बग बाउंट की सीरीज फॉलो भी कर रहे
हैं या अगर आपने नहीं किया है तो अभी से
लेके फॉलो करना शुरू कर सकते हैं इसकी डे
वन से 14th सिंबर तक आप काफी वीडियोस देख
चुके होंगे तो यू आर एलिजिबल स्टूडेंट्स
हैं तो आप यह जरूर फॉलो कर लीजिएगा जिनका
बैकग्राउंड बिल्कुल जीरो है सिक्योरिटी
डोमेन में बिल्कुल जीरो बैकग्राउंड है
उनके लिए यह ट्रेनिंग नहीं है अगर आपका
बिल्कुल जीरो बैकग्राउंड है या आप एक नॉन
आईटी फील्ड से है बट अगर आप आपका
बैकग्राउंड जीरो है तब भी मतलब आपको कुछ
नहीं ज्यादा बेसिक बिल्कुल नहीं पता तो
प्लीज मत इनरोल कीजिएगा हां अगर आप किसी
भी डोमेन से नॉन आईटी आईटी बट आपके पास
बेसिक जानकारी है थोड़ी बहुत चीजें पता है
तो जरूर आप इसमें इनरोल कर सकते हैं ये
सीरीज को फॉलो कीजिएगा बग बाउंट वाली एंड
दैट्ची है फ्रीलांस जो करना चाहते हैं वो
भी जरूर आइएगा ले जिनको जॉब जो जॉब के लिए
एलिजिबल नहीं है काफी एल्डर हैं जॉब नहीं
कर सकते या जॉब नहीं मिलती अब उनको काफी
गैप आ चुका है जॉब नहीं मिल पाएगी या
स्टूडेंट से जॉब नहीं मिल सकती अभी तो
फ्रीलांस प्रोजेक्ट्स आप उठा सकते हैं
वीपीटी के ऊपर में आप अच्छा खासा एक फ्री
रिपोर्ट वीपीटी का तैयार करके किसी भी
कंपनी को उनके ईमेल पे पिच कर सकते हैं
जैसे शक टैंक में पिच किया जाता है अगर
उनको अच्छा लगा तो आपको पेड प्रोजेक्ट वो
आगे से दे देते हैं तो देर आर मल्टीपल
अपॉर्चुनिटी वो आपके ऊपर है ग्रैब करना वो
आपके अपनी वो है ठीक है तो आप उसको देख
लीजिएगा ओके आई होप आप सब समझ गए होंगे तो
आपको सिंपली ffr.in
आ चुके हैं ऑलरेडी मैंने आपको बता दिया है
एंड कुछ बचे हुए हैं उनका इनरोलमेंट लेके
क्लोज कर देंगे इसको ठीक है ये काफी फास्ट
हुआ था क्योंकि स्टार्टिंग के 30 सीट्स तो
24 आवर्स के अंदर में फिल हो गए थे ठीक है
तो अगर आपको बिलीव नहीं हो रहा होगा तो जब
इसकी पहली क्लास होगी ना लाइव इसकी सेशन
तो उस दिन जितने लोग प्रेजेंट रहेंगे मैं
आपको इसका स्क्रीनशॉट लेके शेयर कर दूंगा
डेनिक्स के पेजेस पे ताकि आप लोगों को
बिलीव हो कि हा भैया इतने लोगों ने सच में
इनरोल किया है ऐसे नहीं है तो एवरी बडी गट
टू अंडरस्टैंड राइट और सर अभी भी इनरोल कर
सकते क्या बिल्कुल अभी इनरोल कर सकते हैं
बिल्कुल अभी इनरोल कर सकते हैं अभी आप
इनरोल जब तक ये पेज एक्टिव है मैं आपको
बता रहा हूं जब तक ये पेज एक्टिव है ये
बटंस एक्टिव है ये पेमेंट पेज एक्टिव है
तब तक आप इनरोल कर सकते हैं जब ये पेमेंट
पेज ये बटंस एक्टिवेट नहीं रहेंगे ना तो
ऑटोमेटिक आपको पता चल जाएगा क्योंकि आप
इनरोल कर ही नहीं पाएंगे फिर जाएंगे भी
पेज पे तो इनरोल नहीं कर पाएंगे एटलीस्ट
ठीक है तो आप यू कैन डू डेफिनेटली ड
चलिए बिल्कुल सही शिव शिवम रियल
स्टूडेंट्स तो अभी हैं सर तो ट्रीट लास्ट
में देना चाहिए था रियल स्टूडेंट जो हैं
उनमें से कुछ को ट्रीट नहीं मिल पाई है सर
आपको बताना ही नहीं चाहिए था ट्रीट क्या
है लास्ट में देते आराम से हां यह भी बात
सही है कि रियल स्टूडेंट्स अभी तक है बट
बट स्टिल मैंने देखा काफी ऐसे स्टूडेंट्स
भी थे जो ऑलवेज रहते हैं उस टाइम उनको
मिला है बट कोई बात नहीं जिनको भी ट्रीट
मिला उनको हमारी तरफ से ट्रीट मिला है कोई
भी प्रॉब्लम नहीं है किसी को भी मिला है
मिला है हमने अपने खुशी से दी है वो किसी
को भी दी है वो एक ह्यूमन ही है इंसान है
एंड अगर इस चैनल पे एक बार भी आया है या
अभी आया है तो दैट इज अ बिक ठीक है स वो
हमारे साथी हैं सब लोग ठीक है हैप्पी
टीचर्स डे हैप्पी टीचर्स डे भारत भारत सो
अगेन वंस अगेन गाइ एवरीबॉडी
एंड आप सबको ट्रीट मुबारक आई होप कि आपको
ट्रीट अच्छा लगा होगा जिनको जिनको भी मिला
है जिनको नहीं मिला एक्सट्रीमली सॉरी
ब्रदर बजट के बाहर भी जा रहा था एंड काफी
सारे रिक्वेस्ट आ चुके थे 100 प्स
रिक्वेस्ट स्टिल पेंडिंग थे तो वो चीज मैं
नहीं कर पा रहा था ठीक है तो आई होप यू
कैन अंडरस्टैंड कि ये इसको ए बस एक प्यार
की तरह लीजिए एक जस्ट
जेस्चर फ्रॉम माय साइड ठीक है गुड जेस्चर
फ्रॉम माय साइड
ओके समझ गया
धन्यवाद नौकरी नहीं लगी शादी करें या नहीं
नौकरी नहीं लगी तो शादी तुम्हारी मर्जी है
कर लो नहीं भी करो क्या आ जाता
है न्यू अनाउंसमेंट कब जल्दी होगी जल्दी
अनाउंसमेंट न्यू अनाउंसमेंट लेकर आएंगे
न्यू कोर्सेस की एंड टॉपिक्स
की थैंक्स य बॉय
थैंक्स अच्छा एक दो लोगों ने मुझे भी मेरे
यूपी आईडी पर पेमेंट किया है जैसे एक तो
भारत भी है और भी है कुछ लोगों ने किया था
थैंक यू सो मच आप लोगों ने इतना सोचा कर
दो कुछ लोगों ने सुपर चैट किया है 0 का
धन्यवाद तो आज की सेशन को यहीं पर एंड
करते हैं गाइस आई होप कि आपको समझ में आ
गया होगा टू एंड मल्टी फैक्ट ऑथेंटिकेशन
वाली जो पॉइंट्स है सारी समझ में आ गई
होंगी एंड यह आप किसी को स्क्रीनशॉट लेना
है तो ले सकते हैं ये एंड आप इसमें हंट
करना शुरू कर दीजिए ठीक है बहुत सिंपल सा
है सिंपल सा मेथड था ओके ओके ओके गाइस देन
हैव अ गुड नाइट थैंक यू सो मच अगेन हैप्पी
टीचर्स डे